non non non non
non
ok
josiane ouais c'est thierry ardisson
ah ouais
voilà non seulement ils te font faire
toutes les télés mais en plus et ils te
livre en retard aux télés importante
à quelle porte vous est
à clichy
temps je fais écouter le public un
[Applaudissements]
mois dominique lavanant qui sera en
retard
bonté intérêts de dépêcher parce que moi
je peux pas les tenir là tu vois
ah bah tu vas manger sur le plateau
josiane si tu veux on peut pas avec des
sushis sur le plateau on va s'en occuper
oui
bah je sais mais ils te font faire
toutes les émissions tape pas une minute
entre deux émissions et itil pas à
bouffer et imagine
le public est contre ce galles
maintenant
bon bah je t'embrasse dépêche-toi a tout
de suite ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pinot noir
bienvenue sur le plateau le taux monte à
l'émission
[Applaudissements]
ça va pas dire je suis pas
un
je sais je sais ça y'a quelqu'un au
moment au moment où je vais dire
l'émission qui parle est quelqu'un qui
dit cash avant que j'ai dit qu'ils
parlent tout est foutu en l'air
et il est 2 heures 20 on est tous crever
je sais mais bon qu'est normes et que la
personne se dénoncent ce sera plus
simple si toi bon bah écoute avec nous
ce soir
josiane balasko
we know solo
le bonhomme
thierry frémont
le terme
orion ses nerfs
segura guy bedos
gabriel balancé tu
l' affaire azf
2 0 des blue jays ce thème en juillet
en avril
[Applaudissements]
à
bonsoir tiré le 5 février ce dvd va
sortir ouais c'est un dvd il ya 30 de
comics et un dvd historique parce que tu
sais que les comics se détestent entre
autorités et n'ayant pas été obligé de
se voir ils ont donné disque est je
crois sans donner un sketch est pas et
pas les plus mauvais pour faire un dvd à
15 euros ce qui n'est pas cher pour
regarder donc c'est déjà un dvd
collector et sur les 15 euros 10 euros
iront à la croix rouge car il ya encore
une erreur de communication la croix
rouge est encore besoin de fric bien sur
wii pour pour le tsunami qui a fait des
ravages que tu connais ouais voilà donc
en tout 15 euros ça sort le 5 février
série des deux ans marié
jean marie bigard charal bicarburation
enfin jean-marie l'abri des crédits de
sony déon savez de qui ça venait et il
viendra en parler la semaine prochaine
vous traîner ses cibles pour que les
gens sains s'en souviennent voilà tu
sais que balasko est pas là elle est
enfin dans les embouteillages way
son attaché de presse lui fait faire
trop d'émissions la pauvre elle y arrive
qu elle a fait là le jour du seigneur
whissell et philatélie oui voyage mêlant
d'année en année
[Musique]
alors je dis un peu tes longs
je suis légèrement ta wii voilà ça c'est
clair mais
ouais
bon alors josiane bonsoir de pouvoir
finalement malgré tout tout arrive tout
arrive je suis comme à l'abattage ouais
voilà quelle horreur
l'émission talk show paf c'est terrible
alors sorti mercredi mais ça je pense
que toute la france le sait sorti
mercredi de l'ex-femme de ma vie film
tiré de l'une de vos pièces josiane
balasko film dont vous êtes la
réalisatrice où vous êtes actrice enfin
bon j'imagine que tout le monde le sait
non vous étiez à 19h sur france 2 la
dengue avec nagui
peut-être des gens qui eux savent en
effet face à l'image vous avez un truc
mais pourquoi ils vous font faire tout
ça mais je crois c'est pour parler du
film
parce qu'elle sait que les émissions
terme de cinéma en fait pas d'émission
oui d'accord mais là les deux ans et 3
je crois que la journée j'ai rien
laurent je pense qu'on n'a jamais vu
quelqu'un qui se prostituent et autant
pour
mais bon c'est mon film c'est comme un
enfant mon enfant aurait fait un petit
petit rota pas c'est vrai
que vous avez découvert des émissions ne
connaissiez pas je suis jeté les achats
oui
on va faire à l'envers s il ya quelque
chose sur votre film que vous n'avez pas
encore dit dans toutes ses émissions il
sur moi un truc vous avez conduit ya
sûrement un truc que j'ai dit beaucoup
de choses à raconter indépendamment du
film qu'est-ce que j'ai pas dit mais
j'ai dit pratiquement tous qu'est-ce que
j'ai pas dit j'ai pas parlé et
évidemment effectivement on n'a pas
parlé on a plus parlé du côté comique
mais on n'a pas parlé du côté tendre
ouais bon alors ce que je vais faire je
vais faire le pitch comme si vous veniez
ici pour la première fois j'avais jamais
aucune émission imaginons mal à vous
débarquez josiane balasko sort un film
personnes massées alors le pitch battu
monde le connaît sous x me le répéter
alors puisqu'il est pas mal en plus le
pitch alors thierry lhermitte va se
marier avec nadia farès il dîne avec
elle lorsque débarque l'ex femme de sa
vie voilà alors c'est karine viard qui
est top moche qui est enceinte qui est
fauché lui il l'a pas vue depuis à peu
près sept ans depuis leur divorce mais
il est obligé de l'héberger chez lui
parce que qui peut refuser d'héberger
une femme enceinte surtout que ça
permettra de 5 centimes et qui ne s'est
pas là alors c'est le début d'une longue
série d' embrouille lhermitte veulent à
virer mais il n'y arrive pas il n'a pas
le coeur à la dir est pourtant c'est pas
l'envié qui lui manque karin viard amène
chez lui une psychiatre urgentistes une
femme très aux masses qui marchent avec
les gens des carrés vous trouvez qu'il y
aura 13 mars moi j'ai un connaît des
défis qui sont un peu des femmes un peu
comme si on me dit oui non mais je
trouve assez féminine et sourcils épilés
très haut la main toujours fonctionnel
est ce que vous êtes plus quelque chose
oui voilà donc serre en plus ça fait
partie des choses que karin viard amène
chez lhermitte je ne sais pas comment je
vais apprendre le fait d'être traités de
choses
[Rires]
en fait dans la pièce dont le film est
tiré c'était un mec qui jouait le rôle
mais un psy ouais et ne pouvaient pas
hébergés nina la lingue l'ex-femme de
thierry parce que il habitait chez sa
mère 20 que sa mère habitait avec une
femme qu'il est très jalouse ouais voilà
et là en fait vous qui êtes un homme
opéré je crois qu'on peut le dire vient
ça finira par savoir si même dans la vie
sa fille
quintana mauclair donc finalement vous
vivez avec votre ancienne femme oui bah
c'est pour des raisons de co2 commodités
oui parce que partager vendre un grand
appartement tandis que là on a chacun
chacune et la scène avec avec la cette
actrice formidable à la sylvie herbert
qui fait mon job je vous avais jamais
parlé de sylvia sylvie herbert voilà
c'est la première fois moi ce que l'on
va parler des second la part d'argent
ben oui oui au cinéma on voit très très
peu et cette fille qui est une grande
comédienne finalement être elle a fait
très peu de choses du théâtre et au
cinéma on la voit pas et la difficulté
quand on est un second rôle c'est je
trouve que c'est encore plus dur qu'un
premier parce qu'un premier rôle il ya
plusieurs scènes pour sarah paix peut en
faire une moins bien payés va se
rattraper dans l'autre quand on a qu'une
scène il faut être très bon tout de
suite il faut être impeccable c'est à
dire que on a cinq répliques et dans ces
cinq répliques il faut que le spectateur
contraire son passé son futur le
personnage de caractère et là c'est
typiquement l'exemple d'une actrice
comme ça qu'ils qui d'emblée est
détestable elle est vraiment aimable
comme une porte de prison je crois que
c'est vraiment le moment face à mon
personnage c'est normal et puis on a une
autre aussi que top moche dans le film
c'est karine viard n 1 ou le temps ban à
attendre au début normal quand elle
arrive avec son format n'est accepté de
tourner dans le film ça avait prévenu
alan et rouge et là gros bide elle a les
cheveux gras elle mange comme un porc
enfin vraiment c'est terrible quoi oui
elle a dit oui elle a dit oui non j'ai
alors pour l'anecdote karine je lui
envoie le script et elle me dit ouais
c'est super mais qu'est ce que
j'aimerais jouer son rôle un état dit
mais tu as pas là je tape à l'ag elle va
donc maintenant tu peux pas faire ça
vous l'aviez pas dit ça je sois non ça
veut dire la radio
tout ce que vous avez dit à la radio
est-ce que vous pouvez regarder votre
caméra ouais ça vous l'avez deviné le
cas ailleurs lundi sur internet magnéto
serge
vous pouvez faire mal et auxerre je l'aï
même pas ce que j'ai dit magnéto serge
voilà
gestionnaire ya une dame qui voudrais
vous parler tu ne présente pas
nina mon ex femme ariane ma chance et
c'est pour bientôt deux mois et demi ce
que je peux boire
avait soif excusez moi évidemment jean
plein dîner tu veux là
sa part entré chez moi tom enfin la vie
tu les appelles vient te chercher
marie-pierre la médina était pas
titulaire de noir mari djata pas 36
solutions
sans jamais tu m'entends tu jamais j'ai
déjà commenté ben may be peut-être qu'à
la tête consultez gratuitement
c'est juste la question d'une nuit je te
dédie au bacon est ce que je te
dérangerait pas je ferais pas souri je
te emprunté quelques d'affaires j'ai mis
mes vêtements à laver
vous partez pas très vite toutes les
deux je sens que je vais pas pouvoir me
contrôler je vois que le dialogue est
bloqué qu'est-ce que vous pouvez dégager
7 avant que je vous écris
tu sais ta gueule mais ça c'est très bon
signe ça veut dire qu'il cherche un
autre des lots qu'est ce qui était
arrivé une hydre le soutien des femmes
intelligentes équilibré
j'ai pas dormi de la nuit retournez tout
seul dans ma tête a pleuré sous
l'oreiller
[Applaudissements]
on est adulte maintenant tout a commencé
à avoir des rapports normaux
qu'est ce que t'es c'était ya sept ans
bien 13 trip chaud on a divorcé n'est
plus ma femme
accroché mon vieux c'est pas le moment
vous avez tout à fait sage femme soyons
en sûrs
voilà l'ex femme de ma vie de jeu alors
quoi avec yann danneels côtière
nadia farès voilà un cinéma près de chez
nous wii passe au cinéma ouais ça va
passer au cinéma
et ça sort le 2 février là c'est à dire
mercredi prochain voilà tu as envie
d'aller le voir laurent oui j'ai adoré
la pièce qui a vu plusieurs fois et très
très bonne pièce très bien écrite et
donc oui j'ai envie d'aller voir ce film
on va faire la comparaison
la légende dans ces cas là vous demande
de faire la comparaison les animateurs
télé alors que
vous faites bien ça ben moi par exemple
la distance et moi déjà aux différents
mais bien sûr oui oui vous dites quoi
d'eau
qu'est ce que tu as
tout dit
parlons d'autre chose j'imagine qu'on
vous a déjà posé 50 fois la question sur
l'art formation des bronzés la pause et
oui 50 fois qu'est ce vous dit dans ces
cas là c'est possible quand je dis non
c'est vrai c'est arrivé non maintenant
ça c'est vraiment c'est vrai non mais
c'est plus dans les moeurs est vrai
toujours un peu glissé en général quand
on each à
la rupture merkel souhaitait faire
quelque chose pardon pour les beatles
alors on regarde comme on est en face
tous les deux
les big ben ali alors quand vous vous
retrouvez avec les autres de la bande du
splendid vous parlez de quoi du cac40 de
quoi pourquoi tu balances à tu as une
idée d'arriver dans la tête vous êtes
friche maintenant vers où on est on a du
pognon on est pareil on a du pognon
heureusement qu'on a du pognon ça fait
peut être riche c'est ne plus avoir
besoin de bosser pour gagner de l'argent
voilà c'est toute la différence
c'est évident d intérêt de ce qu'on veut
ce qu'on a en commun voilà les juniors
est d'accord pour la moustache pour la
wii ah ouais ouais ouais ouais mais là
il est le bouc en ce moment il est un
peu tôt il a un peu aidé un peu mal rasé
trois jours rien s'en fout mais correct
mais non il est d'abord il est riche lui
lui peut s'arrêter je ne sais pas
combien il a touché sur les choristes
ils avaient un pourcentage donc là il a
il a joué la nouvelle il a joué gagnant
ouais il a même touché sur titanic je ne
sais pas pourquoi
alors j'imagine aussi qu'on vous a posé
plein de questions sur votre fille
marilou berry mais ça y est oui ça aussi
de la fouille on l'a eue
formidable très sympa vu un truc qu'elle
fait que je vais leur en plus enfin à
l'heure ponctuent
là sa carrière devant elle marie vrais
professionnels mais non mais j'ai bien
élevé c'est la révélation de l'année
mais c'est bien moi je te suis très fier
bravo
ya une chose sexuelle si elle reste
comme ça ça ne fait pas trop de régime
elle peut garder la l'emprise de la
famille sur le segment delà de la
rigolote un panel de maigrir aussi ce
serait dommage ben ouais mais pleure
grossira presse et c'est pas grave les
kilos c'est pas comme le qi les kilos 1
c'est
en tous les cas bravo jamais été
quelqu'un vient vous donner de bons
conseils et on va faire une interview
d'ailleurs conseils pour ma fille
josiane balasko
est ce que vous avez déjà dit à votre
fille arrête de grignoter devant la télé
tu vas finir obèses non non j'ai pas je
n'ai jamais dit arrête de grignoter
parce que si je vous disais même envoyé
balader d'accord est ce que vous l'avez
déjà dit arrête de piquer mes fringues
tu veux ouais ouais ah oui ça je les
récupère et ya peu un bel et bien c'est
vraiment j'ai récupéré ya peu sa force
c'est la première fois que vous le
mettez pas ce que j'avais vu dans le
cloud et non mais elles n'avaient pas 40
ans avec ça
répondait en terre menti aux plaies ça
peut arriver à tout le monde
est-ce que vous lui avez dit tu compte
rester à la maison jusqu'à quel âge
marie l'oat non j'ai pas eu besoin parce
qu'emma 10 et 18 ans je me tire un donc
c'était prévenu est-ce que vous lui avez
dit ça va me faire bizarre marilou mais
je sors avec un indien
ben oui ou non il s'en est aperçu ouais
alors elle le trouve sympa voyons ça se
passe bien très bien on est mariés
maintenant avait plus question de sortir
c'est sérieux c'est du dur est ce que
vous l'avez dit la prochaine fois que tu
me ramènes un mac à la maison c'est un
terreau est le bon je suis pas tellement
mer on amène les copains on va baiser
dans la chambre à côté ça les parents
non moi je pense qu'ils quand on le fait
eh ben on faut être indépendant pour
faire ça faut être indépendant ouais non
faisait ça dans l'autobus avait demandé
à marie voiture n'est pas de je suis
assez d'accord avec ça non je vous
raconte
pas le problème en ce moment ben je veux
pas y penser ça me fait pas envie de
fabriquer les images
c'est pas elle c'est pas un refus de la
sexualité de son enfant simplement que
la sexualité doit se faire en privé
c'est tout et la soul et le témoin les
yeux ou la lorraine témoin de ses
parents c'est pas voilà c'est tout tout
à fait d'accord avec ça mais ça c'est
déjà un point d'entente ans maintenant
alors est ce que vous les avez dit non
ma chérie claude berri ne fait pas
partie de la famille hélas
mais claude berri à dire ayant déjà
travaillé claude berri la connaissait
donc pas à lui dire ça vous avez déjà
dit ça te dirait de fumer un petit pet
avec moi marie l'eau je fume pas un jeu
bois
non j'étais dire je suis même pas non
pas parce que j'ai simplement parce que
quand je fus où j'ai envie de bouffer et
c'est pas nécessaire
est-ce que vous lui avez dit si tu veux
faire ce métier je te préviens tu te
démerdes tout seul
j'ai pas non j'ai pas dit ça m a dit
moment je fais rectrice je fais je pas
dit je veux faire du théâtre l'a pas dit
je te raconte riis et je dis pas que le
pain ça va c'est bon voilà entendu voilà
vous avez dit laisse tomber le ciné il
ya des mecs qui vaudront de sauter là
demain
non j'ai pas eu dire ça parce que je
crois qu'elle d'abord je crois que c'est
une rumeur qui n'existe pas et avec des
mecs ils voudront certainement moi j'ai
jamais moi j'aimerais bien voulu
elle est en retard et drôle
est ce que vous l'avez dit j'étais
interdit de te à poil dans tes
films tu m'entends non non non non non
non non ça c'est elle qui disent je suis
sûr vous lui avez 10 évite le fils
jugnot service l'art comme son père
je sais qu'elle est qu elle est amie
avec le fils jugnot et copines aussi
pareil avec le fils coluche et puis
après je sais pas sur sa vie privée
voilà c'était m est-ce que vous lui
avait dit tu es doué petite conne je lui
dis c'est bien mais j'ai pas dis petite
conne puisque c'est pas la peine selon
est mal pris elle aurait mal pris parce
qu'elle a plus subtilement a dit
pourquoi tu me n'ont
pas mieux
non
c'est un yvan le bolloc'h bruno solo et
thierry vraiment
bonsoir
ok mais c'est josiane balasko fait ma
mère ma mère nourricière c'est la
première fois je le dis ce soir ouais
ouais ça c'est donner ce à quoi ouais
josiane balasko 14 émissions dix jours
je suis
s ils marchent pas ce rapace potins
jorat fédé mais
vous en mettez vous êtes crevé au sima
oui mais ce que nous on sort de la
tournée de province mais ces années de
la bretagne jusqu'à pau a pris la
première dans sa ville natale powe et le
grand marathon commence à partir de
toits talent exclusivités comme
d'habitude merci
ouais je sais c'est terrible se dote ses
tournées en province comme ça le soir
dans vous discutez avec les spectateurs
du film tard dans la nuit après vous
allez boire un coup et c'est la seule
occasion qu'ont et c'est pour ça que je
trouve assez agréable et rencontres avec
le public est vrai que c'est vraiment
intéressant
j'étais en plus j'ai tout entendu ce que
tu a balancé avant le début d'émission
c'est navrant moi je te déteste chez les
couilles de liège est passé à manger des
sushis j'ai mangé des sushis en trois
minutes au nom temps va encore non
genève au mieux
en tous les cas bruno ivan c'est
magnifique de sérieusement de vous voir
encore ensemble tous les deux dans ce
métier où viennent dur finalement gars à
qui un devoir mais avec la toujours non
mais moi je vous ai fait rencontrer mais
vous êtes toujours ensemble après toutes
ces années ce avant 15 ans toujours à 60
mais c'est toujours pas la proportion il
faut fermer ta gueule
est ce que est ce que des fois vous vous
dites je laime ce mec ouais ouais ouais
ouais des x games annonce moi je suis
breton tu sais mais je peux quand même
confié comme ça fait 10 comme un menhir
vous vous dites que vous aimez tous les
deux des fois ouais on se le dit ouais
bien sûr qu'on se le dise tard le soir
non pas tard le soir tôt le matin
le plus besoin de l'autre
hommage aux pas répond ce serait
dégueulasse pour yvan ça
est-ce que vous avez déjà pleuré l'un
devant l'autre oui l'un dans l'autre non
non non c'était pour quelque chose de
2,2 dans ces terribles où on a pleuré
l'un devant l'autre on s'est souvent
pris dans les bras pour des moments
douloureux en 15 ans tu attends de voir
passer des choses et des gens et les
voir disparaître aussi vite là non on va
c'est qu'ils prennent toi tout à l'heure
tu as marathonien ça fait des années
qu'il ya des choses que vous êtes jamais
dit et que vous auriez envie de vous
dire ce soir on n'y a pas de choses
cachées quand ils m'agacent je lui dis
je pense que c'est son manteau par
exemple mon manteau acquis à toi moment
tout est acquis c'est bon c'est un
moment tôt à quai à quai sa demande
il est bien décidé salle bon manteau moi
j'aime bien mais son manteau puisqu'il
ya ils sont bientôt ce pas lui dire mais
non je formule 1 12e manche de sa femme
en blessant au
c'est ce qui attire mon merveilleux là
il est super sont beaux mais si j'allais
te le dire bien sûr je trouve grotesque
avec son manteau
alors vous êtes ici pour un crime vous
aussi et oui et qui sort quand je te
rassure en même temps comme suit josiane
ya un bon film qui va sortir jours la
damnation décider lequel
vous avez la promo qu'elle a fait sept
morts c'est du dévouement aux chasse
neige salut a tous fait faire segal tous
la même fait face à l'image le samedi
après midi c'est vrai sur france 2 tu
étais bien d'ailleurs été séparés des
indiens wayana ça ouais bien alors
espace détente donc c'est basé sur le
concept caméra café mais c'est pas une
suite de sketches c'est un film où vous
dites des choses qui vous tiennent à
coeur
il ya une phrase qui vient je crois
qu'elle est toi d'ailleurs un humour
deux classes qui soit classe ouais j'ai
pensé les deux mois je veux qu'elle est
bien allé bien avant le l'a dit oui
c'est un peu embêtant mais dès que tu me
laisses la palmeraie de faire un pitch
n'est même pas le croire
d'un nouveau produit qui arrive dans
cette petite pme de province totalement
sclérosé qui vit sur son lustre d'antan
et qui va bouleverser
les âmes qui va bouleverser les
personnages et qu'elle est obligée à se
changer et à bouger enfin alors qu'il ne
bouge plus depuis des années est le
personnage qui vient semer la zizanie
c'est thierry frémont il faut toujours
dans une comédie quelqu'un qui vient de
l'extérieur pour faire éclater le cette
belle ordonnance et c'est thierry
frémont qui vient la merde dans
ce petit paradis un peu mesquin qui la
veulent puisque ça se passe dans la
ville région que m'a inventé pour
l'occasion de traverser le fleuve qui
s'appelle la torv et dont le le
chef-lieu et chimie
mais sur glaize bagnon le vase et
flétrie le pinson une région qu'on n'a
pas envie de visiter par contre il ya un
bonheur à filmer et puis un parc au loup
aussi c'est la seule attraction alors
oui effectivement il ya bolloc'h donc il
juge jean claude convenant donc il y a
deux obsessions trompé sa femme 1 sa
femme qui est abruti d'antidépresseurs
qui a deux enfants kevin et la toya
s'est bien trouvés natalia oui bah il
n'y a pas beaucoup de gens qui rendent
hommage à la toya jackson elle a changé
de nom je connais
c'était l'occasion pour
et alors c'est notre obsession c'est
construire la véranda de sa maison un
oui pour pouvoir quitter sa femme voilà
parce que ça lui a promis et comme c'est
un type bien il aura le cul propre idée
et alors toi donc tu fais hervé dumont
du monde a en mémoire de l'écolo du
monde tu t'ai appelé du mans j ai jamais
pensé mais effectivement c'est drôle
c'est drôle le pape de l'écologie en
france c'était rené dumont et pierre
fournier montante on voit là et toi t'es
hervé dumont dont je suis moi la
maternité un syndicaliste bas de gamme
c'est que eux profitent de la situation
qui menace sans arrêt de le déclencher
une grève enfin si tu vois là alors je
suis pour mieux pactiser avec les
patrons derrière voilà c'est une crapule
c'est vraiment un jaune je suis un
jaunissement alors cette entreprise donc
elle a un produit qui est un homme ainsi
seraient électriques est un dérivé de la
gégène en fait parce qu'au départ cette
société a pesé la gégène et puis comme
il ya plus besoin de gégène elle fait
des investisseurs elle est très adapté
leur enlever quelques voltage pour
pouvoir voilà ça s'appelle le 6 14 voilà
exactement mais tout comme che c'est
l'idée du capitalisme tout peut se
réutilisées c'est comme si les phares
bonne qui faisait de zyklon b et qui
aujourd'hui continue à faire des
produits ou krups qui faisait les canons
pour l'armée allemande costume de
l'armée allemande lagerfeld
cette société fabrique classé 14 mai le
pdg veut lancer un nouveau produit qui
s'appelle le body compact voilà voilà et
c'est ça qui va jeter cette entreprise
dans les affres du libéralisme
voilà le libéralisme sans foi ni loi
l'ultralibéralisme 1 c'est comme au
blind test quand c'est le chacun pour sa
gueule c'est l'ultra libéralisme est
incarné par thierry frémont voilà qui
s'exprimera tout à l'heure
c'est thierry frémaux vouloir
délocaliser la fabrication et à peu près
je tiens est vraiment qu'il va vouloir
délocaliser la fabrication de ce nouveau
produit et conquérir le marché américain
voilà et vous vous allez vous opposez
tous les deux mais pour de mauvaises
raisons à cet assaut mondialistes voilà
c'est bien ainsi s'il est bien bien
autrement mais c'est pas mal c'est pas
mal
si vous préférez le pitch de thierry
ardisson vous tapez 1
bien alors vous allez regarder tous les
trois caméras même deux méritent pas
tout de suite
je crois qu'il aurait été prévue la
semaine prochaine
si décalage quand on tolère mais tu
fermes ta gueule très bien
nantes y aller c'est pas vrai tu as il
ya un gros truc sur toi
camarade l'homme était très bien hu 4
magnéto serge cependant il apparaît
pourriture mais j'étais même pas du tout
aux jus moi quoi vous vous y coller les
tensions à droite même et auxerre
ou de la dyarchie nous sommes une équipe
et voici le body compact c'est un
produit résolument novateur il
représente l'avenir du fitness à mon
histoire à domicile c'est parti jean
claude convenant je représente la
société jugée n'est pas ça m'intéresse
ces domaines c'est un produit formidable
ça va je me gare
aux employés sont un peu en léthargie à
l'image de l'entreprise
[Musique]
c'est jean claude qui joue intégration
mais ils ont du potentiel qu'est ce qui
se passe assez ternes et d'agréable à
ras réactivité
souplesse
se lancer dans l'international n'est pas
une partie de plaisir
mais je suis confiant nous avons le
potentiel pour y arriver pour mémoire
les stats s de réputation le costume par
harvey désire s est tu viens offrir
d'autres entreprises ont été prises en
matière de délocalisation et de sous
traitance internationale
[Musique]
c'est bien sûr
il semble
[Musique]
soit
jean neveu nac et sur l'eau
étiez vous
et aussi notre invité
c'est sympa
on est 100
ça c'est là c'est la chanson une des
chansons du film s'appelle l'amérique
par ses bas le petit clin d'oeil un peu
amusant c'est qu'on voulait faire
chanter par des algériens la chanson
l'amérique voilà pour juste pour
rappeler que le rêve américain
appartient à tout le monde il reste que
ce qu'affirme le petit texan là bas m'a
énervé et voilà c'est un petit clin
d'oeil ça nous amusait de le faire
puisqu'on avait pensé à appeler le film
ce n'est pas l'amérique parce que quand
vous allez devoir vous rendez compte que
c'est tout sauf l'amérique le film bien
et nous en arrivons maintenant à thierry
fremont à thierry frémont bruno
dites-vous c'est un bosseur
il arrive vierge qu'est ce que tu veux
que je fasse il donne tout toujours
donne tout et plus encore
ce type est touché par la grâce c'est un
type rare
et pas très cher
non mais c'est vrai que
c'est une vraie amitié quinquina qui
nous lie maintenant
mais qui vont avec bruno ça fait deux
films qu'on fait ensemble et on a déjà
partagé que plein de moments avec yvan
aussi donc je suis touché par des cas
bravo
[Rires]
mais c'était vrai que c'était tout
c'était pour le personnage c'était assez
important dans ce type qui arrive
quelques étranges sont comme une lame
qui est un champion de
l'ultralibéralisme qui sans foi ni loi
qui n'a pu c'est le personnage qui n'est
pas démagogique ya pas les méchants
patrons et les bons ouvriers tout le
monde en prend pour son grade lui aussi
est une victime système donc mais d'un
coup sa revanche allait elle est
terrible le film est réalisé par vous
deux ouais vous aviez déjà réalisé les
sketches de caméra café ouais donc que
vous savez comment on faisait c'est à
dire qu'on pensait que pour la direction
d'acteur il y avait personne d'autre que
nous qui pouvons assumer ce rôle et
quant à au fait de faire un film la
technique quand vous entoure et bien
quand vous savez à qui vous avez
travaillé quand vous faites le le
découpage avant que vous prévoyez
absolument tout il n'y avait pas
beaucoup de surprises pour l'arrivée sur
le plateau on savait vraiment ce qu'on
allait faire donc après tout un film
c'est quelque chose votre match parce
que moi ça m'intéresse moment vous
partager la tâche on y parle de tueries
mais non mais je recommande
qu'ils menaient ces travaux
moi ça m'intéresse parce que c'est vrai
que moi je mets en scène j'ai personne
pour me diriger là c'est vraiment le
problème donc je coupe ce n'est pas bon
à l'arrivée toi mais vous vous y êtes
dans tout l'étagé au niveau technique
mais et direction d'acteurs ont fait ça
à tour de rôle comment ça se passe
exactement quand je le vendrais c'est
l'arrière et vice et versa et sinon on a
décidé que de bruno serait le porte
parole de nos deux voix parce que si on
se met à discuter tous les deux en même
temps donner d'indication sur un plateau
c'est un bordel donc c'était la voix de
bruno et puis
préférences lautner les tontons
flingueurs au niveau des dialogues sans
aucun doute voix c'est plus fort que
nous mais ouais ça serait plutôt dire
quoi one way est bien peu tard jean
yanne tout le monde il est beau tout le
monde il est gentil tomoki aussi les
comédiennes comme affreux sales et
méchants c'est un peu le cinéma qui qui
nous qui nous anime quoi tuer dans
lequel on aspire il ya un peu des bonzes
et on espère modestement ouais mais nous
dès qu'on a commencé à écrire caméra
café mais même la série on s'est
toujours inspiré des passages de bronze
et notamment les bronzés font du ski
lorsque vous regardez vraiment qui sont
les personnages je pense pas que vous me
dire le contraire josiane c'est des
personnages qui fondamentalement mauvais
mais on les aime il ya aucune
condescendance aucun mépris pour ses
personnages alors qu'en fait c'est comme
une bande de potes qui se tirent bande
dont ils sont absolument odieux nous
c'est pareil dans la série on a voulu
avoir un regard tant sur les personnages
qui sont un peu médiocre mais au sens
presque littéraire du terme quoi mais
pour pas que ce soit aussi stéréotypés
dans la série on est passé un peu
derrière les personnages on les a
montrés autrement dit et ça c'est la
force d'un film de pouvoir tirer les
situations revenons à toiture et quelle
est ta couleur
blanche
à tous les cas ça a toutes les chances
de marcher un ben nous on l'a fait pour
ça marche je connais pas beaucoup de
gens qui font des films pour 10 portant
vous êtes peut-être les futurs stars du
cinéma français j'ai adoré ton peut-être
avaient-ils et la prudence il a priori
vous avez raison mais je pense pas non
non on va voir on va faire une interview
superstar
[Musique]
au point de deux stars étude où vous en
êtes aujourd'hui ça vous embête pas de
faire de la promo moi ça me fait chier
mais faut le faire et c'est me l'a
demandé mais je fais mon cher bons
petits soldats de satan mais pas de
faire de la promo il vend la promo rien
à foot ça va marcher toute façon
hors d'eux c'est du bonbon ouais vous
désirez quelque chose en particulier là
maintenant oui je vois bien à homard à
l'armoricaine s'il te plaît même si vous
êtes filmés de drogue des questions
préparées à l'avant ce bond à celle on
les connaît tous vas-y la suivante elle
m'a beaucoup fait rire d'ailleurs
fort n'appelle pas à tout le monde te
connais pas ici présentes poète et qui
tuent fait l'interview je sais même pas
qui tu es
tarifs et l'âge mais la dynamique
ça ne dérange pas le rapport nommé
christian était gosse cie dans ce sens
ma musique quand je faisais de la
musique un lego syrie de mes blagues et
toi t'es qui tu vas quoi laisser comme
trace comme disait prévaut à l'autre là
ça ne dérange pas de répondre à mes
questions mais non ça ne dérange pas un
nazi l'histoire les jeunes qui débutent
vous êtes comporté a laissé une tache a
comme tâche
je tombe sur ce plateau ce soir je
compte en effet monde la décoration
quand même sceptique et facebook c'est
bien pourquoi oui bidon puis pour
acheter chez pas le niveau de l'harmonie
des couleurs et tout c'est une farce que
le verre et du violet etc c'est quoi ces
lisbonne ici ou quoi
bon allez vas-y passe à ce bon vieux
continent est réalisateur et acteur les
producteurs aussi ouais on est
producteur déjà pourquoi vous avez pas
fait la musique nous la fait quasiment
l'année l'amérique c'est moi qui
l'inspira joe dassin ya quelques années
attention quand même important
non je ris afin que toi aussi je peux me
la péter parce que tu vois tes nous les
vivants le boulet que j'ai dû ce cas là
comment j'appelle moi
les listes frêche est retourné une
histoire c'est une saison qui boivent du
café c'est ça c'est assez dépouillé
c'est un peu comme bergman non
voilée on est censé être star dans un
magasin on est sans cesse la
panique et tu la cupra je pensais que ce
film peut faire mieux bien tu veux la
fécofoot en revanche sans womé avocat
d'accord
vous pensez que ce film peut faire mieux
que le titanic
s'est pas quitté nique géant et
voilà c'est ça le dessin animé là ouais
avec la petite fille lola qui se la pète
il s'est pris pour un aviateur c'est ce
qu'en chaise la non attends sérieux
sérieusement on parle de cinéma là
honnêtement dans le cinéma français
cette médiocrité autour de vous c'est
pas gênant non au contraire au contraire
ça nous permet de briller d'éclater ça
permet d'écraser un peu plus
au contraire je me sens bien autour des
médiocres mois on a duré près terminée
j'ai pas des mines
[Applaudissements]
et du magicien les gens qui tombent oui
qui tombe sur interviews et qui zappe
juste là dessus j'ai vu solo mon
frère où il était poli mais selon le
bolloc'h mais attends ils ont pris un
melon ces deux canards asf c'est affreux
à ce niveau de jeu dans le monde via
qu'il ya de niro quoi et encore de niro
de niro sa carrière à capter peut-être
un peu derrière lui quand même dire non
ça fait quoi d'avoir fait aucun mauvais
film jusqu'à maintenant
ça fait plaisir
[Rires]
c'est vrai que woody allen va faire un
remake qui va s'appeler koffi caméra
oui oui les questions que vous dit on le
fasse mais enfin c'est quand même moi
qui attirait ses textes et qu'il
dirigerait arm pas laisser à ceux
baltringue la tuer le soin de s'occuper
de mes affaires quels conseils comme si
woody allen il a fait ses preuves ce
mec-là fondamentalement dix mois le
nombre d'entrées qu'il a fait son effet
d'entraînement avec les mairies terre a
mérité de jay recettes et ce film tu vas
faire 9 millions bondy moi juste logique
[Applaudissements]
et c'est qui est la nôtre kaunas mais
bon
la série sera fêté à ce qu'elle quels
conseils donneriez à une jeune
comédienne comme jason burt a été tout
de suite
je crois que j'étais chahuté et tu veux
faire
c'est les jeunes si le film marche si le
film marche vous reviendrez ici par
gossio
brigade et invitera dans notre émission
s'est levé demain
[Musique]
selon vraiment espace des cantonales
messieurs
quand il est bien
[Musique]
si on tirait une petite carte
alors
[Applaudissements]
vous devez vous devez changer votre
personnalité avec votre voisin de gauche
pendant 10 minutes
iata pas le talent pour ça alors le
sombre héros pendant 10 minutes
moi je dois raconter une histoire drôle
et vas-y alors une histoire drôle c'est
un type qui veut acheter un perroquet
pour faire un cadeau à sa fille alors il
arrive dans un
une oisellerie et puis voilà un premier
perroquet ah c'est beau un arabe tout en
couleurs magnifiques un superbe
perroquets et voit le prix ils voient
5000 euros 1000 euros un
perroquet mais qu'est ce qu'il fait
écoutez il parle anglais il fait la
traduction simultanée
il tape sur internet il envoie le
courrier il prépare les bébés le bacon
le matin ah oui effectivement et puis là
il se balade dans l'oise et refill c'est
de trouver moins cher il tombe sur un
cacatoès magnifique et tout blanc et aux
superbes 10000 euros
dix mille euros le 14 mai qu'est ce qui
fait de plus que l'autre ah bah lui
reçoit et on y fait à manger il fait le
ménage également et vit pas si langue
voilà ah oui d'accord et puis un peu
plus loin le magasin il en voit qui est
tout pourri tout des plumes et
dégueulasse quoi être complètement
cacochyme qui s'apprête à classer et il
voit le prix 35000 euros mais qu'est ce
qu'il fait y est affreuse celui ci
qu'est ce qu'il a de plus écoutez je
sais pas il parle jamais mais les deux
autres l'appel patron
voilà avec quoi que ce soit un quartier
très dur je vais dire du mal de sur
manuel c'est moche ah non non non je
vais vomir dessus
oui méfions des apparences
[Rires]
qu est ce qu a faire ils vont peut être
venir bruno pendant 10 minutes écoute je
vais rien faire parce que si j'étais
bruno solo j'aurais dit à l'autre
connard qui arrivent et qui est un
manteau en peau de chèvre qui failli
changer de mentor immédiatement alors
voila tu fais ce que tu peux te mettre
deux boucles fois tu veux je vais te
dire franchement gênant
il est super beau
départementaux mais voilà il ya un côté
bhp
tu vois
pas bordeaux ma femme m'a dit tu veux à
la télévision tu vas t'acheter quand
même un vêtement classe alors en tulle m
son manteau beaucoup de l'admettre je
crois que c'est un pas que je ne
franchirai pas
chacun marine delterme et florian zeller
c'est quoi le scat mans ce soir
et c'est josiane balasko bien sûr voilà
yvan le bolloc'h bonsoir
3 qu'est ce qu'il ne fait bien
thierry frémont que l'essai que j'avais
vraiment sera coupée au montage
des tests physiques
je sais les jeux s'est dit qu'il allait
causer et je sais qu'un grand film qui
va arriver mais tu ne ressens rien on
parler de ça francis heaulme c'est
énorme à quel point vous ressemblez
c'est un habitant sur huit a eu sa loge
et du site alors est-ce qu'en lettieri
c'est vrai c'est incroyable la
ressemblance est un cran plus quand on
sait à quel point vous rentrez dans vos
personnages on a peur déjà j'aimais
d'une descente en enfer est vraiment
très très bien réalisé je dois faire
quelque chose comme d'incarner francis
ou le monde doit devenir un peu sérieux
qui leur bout d'un moment non non c'est
simplement une descente dans la misère
avec la plus absolue mort à la misère
intellectuelle mais tout est laid quoi
mais c'est le jeu j'ai aucune empathie
pour lui ni aucun objet de la
miséricorde pour lui mais je veux dire
son île son sac était bien remplie pour
en arriver là mais vous le détestez pas
vous vous vous avez un peu la corde la
compassion non pas la compassion la
miséricorde marine vous étiez étudiante
en droit à assas quand vous étiez
pendant marine vous avez marine te le
dis bien c'est après que ça merde
[Rires]
marine vous étiez étudiant en droit à
assas lorsque vous avez été accosté par
un japonais qui parlait pas français qui
vous a entraîné dans l' agence karin
models et là on vous a demandé de vous
mettre en maillot de bain et vous avez
refusé oui parce que je dois préciser
qu'il était minuit quand même quand on
m'a demandé de me mettre en maillot de
bain au milieu d'une fête je suis me
suis dit que c'était pas très c'était
pas mon truc voilà six ans parti chez
moi mais après vous avez été accostée
une ou deux fois et cette fois ça a
marché oui voilà on m'a amené dans une
agence qui s'appelait oui qu'ils étaient
deux femmes charmantes moi quand j'ai
commencé à travailler comme ça et là
pendant deux ans vous avez connu le
monde enchanté des top models vous
habitiez dans un grand loft à new york
avec carla bruni
ça va être sympa chanteuse absolument
vous passez vos soirées avec mick jagger
avec avec robert de niro avec eric
clapton c'est vrai ça oui c'est vrai
c'était drôle ah oui c'est sympa
d'ailleurs mais bien sûr quand on a 20
ans et j'ai une vie de rêve déjà vous
non
c'était c'était une vie de rêve je ne
sais pas en tout cas c'était c'était des
rencontres c'était à new york ces deux
villes assez étonnante où tout le monde
se rencontrent les parents les deux
musiciens que moyens il n'y a plus rien
qui peut vous étonnez vous après ce que
vous avez vécu non
quand on est unique jeger robert de niro
le talon oui c'est ça en fait alors en
fait vous rêviez de devenir comédienne
malgré votre vie de top model
successfull essais godard qui vous ont
engagé pour un moyen métrage ça s'est
passé comment avec lui
très bien gt gt un rôle dans son petit
village lula vient un studio on a
enregistré là-bas on a filmé là bas et
il était charmant il était il avait très
peur pour nous on était trois jeunes
comédiens et c'est que c'était un
s'était pas c'était dur de commencer à
faire ça et qu'on souffrirait beaucoup
alors j'étais un peu impressionné je les
ai écoutés mais il était charmant alors
voilà donc le top model lundi lors film
avec godard quelques films par la suite
vie très difficile ensuite vous faites
un enfant et aujourd'hui vous avez une
rente de situation vous avez une série
sur tf1 il série récurrente en mai
c'était un parcours tout tracé quoi
aujourd'hui vous êtes alice nevers le
juge est une femme sur tf1 c'est vrai
que c'est un bon tube on gâche non ça
marche ça marche c'est bien ça très
content c'est si je les fais je vais
arrêter travaillé pendant deux ans pour
des raisons personnelles et c'est vrai
que
dans le lot voilà qu'après voilà il ya
des trucs non mais et c'est vrai que
c'est c'est un statut un peu particulier
d'être héroïne d'une série c1 je pense
qu'on peut le réussir que si on
s'investit vraiment on peut pas le faire
comme ça en passant un peu on a en
débarquant sur un ton argent c'est vrai
que j'ai accès aux ça sera avec les
auteurs
on travaille ensemble on suit plus
qu'une comédienne la danse dans ce cas
là et donc c'est plutôt excitant dans
des idées on cherche voilà une belle
aventure parcours exemplaire en plus
vous avez un hobby comme ça fait de la
sculpture donc vous enfermer chez vous
pour faire des sculptures donc vous êtes
parfait voilà bien une passion sans
pression mais ça ça doit être au dessus
bon
mini d'exemplaires vue avec ses écrits
par un romancier votre vie arrêt
à 6 alors aurions aussi parcours
absolument exemplaire et 25 ans vous
êtes chargé de cours de littérature à
sciences po vous avez fait trois romans
dont le dernier la fascination du pire a
eu le prix interallié 2004 deux pièces
qui sont sur scène en ce moment dont une
le manage ou marine vous aussi c'est
exemplaire qua
non je ne sais pas c'est dire si jeune
dix exemplaires mais c'est un accident
un petit peu de la vie c'est à dire que
une pièce et c'est une longue histoire
le moment où les cris et le moment de
jouer il se passe plein de choses il
faut réunir des comédiens rencontrer des
directeurs de théâtre aux côtés des
producteurs donc c'est long donc là il
se trouve que c'est tombé au même moment
mais c'est un accident de la vie et
voilà tu trouves pas qu'ils ont des
destins exemplaires tous les deux vous
êtes magnifique marine vous êtes sur
scène dans une pièce de florian zeller
s'appelle le manège mise en scène par
nicolas briançon qui joue aussi
d'ailleurs avec le fameux nicolas vaude
et
pourquoi on vient du mot et
blessant lundi pendant des mois qu'il
fallait dire venez vous êtes à venir
c'est votre nom ah bon je me dis ah les
deux c'est vrai vous allez c'est drôle
sera coupe moi je dit woods voilà on n'a
rien prévu un vote
florian cette pièce vous l'avez écrit de
pau pour marine en fait oui c'est dire
j'ai enfin j'ai eu la chance de l'écrire
pour les acteurs qui la joue et puis
donc notamment pour marine et puis
nicolas nicolas vaude et donc c'est à
dire que je les écris pour marine parce
que j'avais envie justement de vivre ça
avec elle et puis aussi 100 ans sans que
ce soit elle sur scène mais en tout cas
ce que je percevais ou ce que j'ai entre
apercevez de sa grâce où sa pause ils
tous qui me touche et en tout cas en l
j'avais envie que que ça existe comme ça
aussi sur scène donc c'est vrai que j'ai
écrite pour elle
alors ça s'appelle le manège alors on
dit pas un pitch au théâtre on vit un
argument c'est thierry je sais bien
puisque
jérôme deschamps broder un comme sacha
guitry 1
[Rires]
donc l'argument c'est faites comme chez
vous 1 c'est à dire en général quand on
dit à quelqu'un faites comme chez vous
fait comme chez toi c'est une formule de
politesse et c'est l'histoire de
quelqu'un qui prend ça un peu au premier
degré et qui s'incruste un petit peu
dans le salon et dans l'espace vital
d'une femme qu'il a aimée et puis
convoque comme ça tous les fantômes qui
sont entre 2 c'est-à-dire les amants
qu'ils ont été les amants qui ne sont
plus ce qu'ils auraient voulu être et
puis donc ça devient une espèce de
labyrinthe dans lequel on se perd dans
lequel on rigole et puis dans lequel on
se retrouve parfois si ça marche bien
vous accepté de parler de votre relation
vous considérez que c'est du domaine de
la vie privée tous les deux c'est une
question piège là je sais que les yeux
brillent je sens qu'ils aient déjà de
trois milles derrière rien tu savais pas
qu'ils étaient ensemble mais temps c'est
toute leur vie privée peut-être que toi
et la tête
c'est mort non mais il faut reconnaître
que tirer et très respectueux sur ce
bout parce que celui-ci attend s'ils
veulent pas en parler de manière ils ont
besoin
ça n'aura pas une seule rien n'était pas
au courant toi qu'est ce t'en passer
pour un couple magnifique et si on les
voit séparément on se dit tiens il
serait il serait très bien dans ce voilà
vous a sérieusement réduit vous avez du
coup je suis prof de littérature à
sciences po il vous a fait ce coup là
non non pas du tout il
n'existe pas d'accord du tout de suite
pour aborder dans la rue en disant j'ai
un cours de littérature à sciences po il
n'y a pas de cours de cette littérature
et sciences mais que fait-il pendant
toutes ces heures dans cette chose je
sais pas ce qu'ils font
mais aussi pour ça au fond que j'ai
qu'on a fait du théâtre ensemble parce
que ce qui est vraiment pratique quand
quant à financer tous au théâtre tous
les soirs c'est quand on dispose de deux
heures de liberté absolue ce que je fais
là
mais non mais c'est pour une actrice il
faut pas dire je donne des cours de
littérature et sciences po l'annoncé
c'est à dire mais qu'il faut le dire
mais c'est pas je suis producteur de
cinéma j'écris un scénario en ce moment
c'est pour toi comme ça non justement en
fait j'ai rien dit j'ai rien fait c'est
peut-être pour ça que ça arrive à écrire
écoutez les conseils sont nés et ont
dépensé on la lui l'a écouté ça marche
chez toi on croit toujours qu'il faut
parler nous n'ont pas nécessairement
c'est vrai que tu sais où tu es toi mais
je croirais 1 mais une fois que j'ai
bien parlé
alors quand quelqu'un a écrit une pièce
pour vous comme moi monsieur le cas là
vous êtes obligé de la trouvais bien ces
sacs à merde on on imaginer qu'elles
soient pas bien j'ai de la chance allait
elle est superbe
mais si elle avait été absolument médium
qu'est ce qui serait bien c'est un
premier test en public voilà premier
test de votre amour non c'est pas je
pense pas que sous statut t'écris très
bien je pense pas que ça aurait été
mieux par contre ça aurait pu vraiment
ne pas me parler comme ça j'ai déjà lu
dessinée patois des scénarios que je
ferme que j'adore mais certains voient
là c'est parce qu'on peut faire de ça ça
ne démarre pas tu dis pas qu est ce qu
elle ferait dans un lac est ce qu'elle
écouterait comme j crew est quelque
chose qui ne marche pas donc là c'est
malhonnête de faire ça bon j'aurais dit
non au foie katie t'a d'y aller bien bah
oui elle est bien appuyé sur tout l été
compliqué ouais c'est excitant la fiche
une quand même à la fin non ça
voilà j'aime dire que je l'avais écrite
pour elle et puis juste derrière vous
dit que c'est une dans sur scène
on dirait que j'ai un peu c'est pas tout
à fait elle sur scène c'est à dire je
l'écrive pour elle sauf effectivement à
la fin on comprend que c'est une salle
d'eau d'accord
on peut savoir
ce qu'il a fait trois bouquins jusqu'à
maintenant les trois bouquins c'est
trois naufrages sentimentaux quand même
hein c'est vrai donc il ya une
prédisposition mais quand je les
rencontre et j'avais rien de lui donc
j'étais très très gentil finalement
voilà on s'est rencontré il m'a il m'a
interviewé il m'a écouté ah oui vous
interview c'était pour l'officiel donc
il vient vous interviewez vous êtes sûr
grande amie carla bruni que vous avez
connu à new york
interviewé sur les voies et non le
magnétophone était en panne et ça c'est
très malin parce que les deux gonzesses
tu l aimes bien aidé le côté un peu
faible du mac on va l'aider mais c'est
vrai que je devais faire un portrait
comme on fait parfois des portraits
d'actrices comme ça et je suis venu avec
un magnétophone en panne et voilà
l'interview s'est prolongée parce que le
magnétophone ne marchait pas et puis ça
fait deux ans que moi mon magnétophone
aurait marché c'est quand
mais l'une chez nous apporte une petite
carte
[Musique]
c'est génial j'ai la carte chance je
suis dispensé de dire magnéto serge se
tiendra à
toi vous devez jeter un verre d'eau sur
l'animateur à la première occasion
bon d'accord donc mais l'humain petit
verdot pour le fera minute lorient un
petit pourquoi petit basque il va le
cheveu sur moi à oui mais bon va t'en
doutes tu choisis a écrit petit ver
morts alors voilà c'est à nous les mois
un petit tonneau plus tôt ils sont une
belle occasion une bonne occasion
m
du petit montparnasse un manège le
croyant nerfs avec marine delterme
chacun est lancée durera
m
bonsoir laurent segura vous êtes
l'épousé d'andré segura un ancien
braqueur site est unanimement comme un
exemple de réinsertion sociale père de
famille modèle tranquillement installé
dans le dans le midi aujourd'hui
réclamée par la belgique pour des
hold-up qu'il a commis là bas en vertu
de la loi perben 2 donc la france est
obligée d'extrader votre mari c'est des
faits qui remontent à 22 93 10 10
novembre 93 et cette loi est rétroactive
jusqu'en 93 - jusqu'au 1er au 10
novembre 93 ou à quelque chose près quoi
à croire qu'ils ont fait cette loi
spécialement pour mon mari voilà et si
vous voulez dans d'autres pays ce mandat
d'arrêt européen ils remontent jusqu'en
2000 2002 et c'est la france qui le fait
partir aussi loin que ça déjà qu'un
première interrogation la nation que je
me pose donc il se fait arrêter au moi
de jouer il est placé dans les qhs
alors qu'il est sorti par la grande
porte il est passé par neuf cour
d'assises il a payé sa dette disons à la
société on l'a libéré il a été surveillé
il travaille il travaillait il a
réintégré notre famille et nos deux
filles et elles seront une a fait dix
jours de détention et les juges de nîmes
ont décidé de le libérer
le procureur a fait cassation et là on
s'est retrouvé devant la cour de
cassation on a été renvoyé à lyon alors
alors allez savoir je me pose deuxième
point d'interrogation pourquoi lyon
parce que normalement étant de nîmes le
6 avignon montpellier voire aix en
provence mais jamais lyon là on a été
renvoyé à lyon est là lyon a confirmé 1
voilà de le renvoyer huit années en
belgique sachant que j'habite dans le
sud de la france alors là c'est
ça dépasse tout entendement c'est le
coup de massue qu'on a pris sur la tête
le coup de massue qu'à prier monsieur
patrick maranon son patron qui est
totalement révoltés parce que moi ça
fait quand même ça fait plus d'un an et
demi qui travaillaient avec mon mari qui
lui a même confié sur l'entreprise s'est
installée une confiance et un mec
bosseur jeu avec le parcours qu'on a eu
moi je me suis battue comme maintenir
mes liens familiaux parce qu'en france
on maintient rien du tout c'est dans
l'intérêt quand même de la société que
quelqu'un se réinsère ou à ce moment là
qu'ils fassent un poteau qui comme
chaque fois qu'il ya un mec qui rentre
au lieu de construire de nouvelles
prisons qui vont bondé qui vont bien
remplir je peux vous le dire et le
veulent carrément le fusiller voilà mon
mari l'a pas de sang sur les mains il a
jamais tué personne il n'a jamais même
usé de violence ça a été reconnue par
neuf cour d'assises lesquels des par des
jurys populaires ont décidé de procéder
à ce qu'on appelle à une confusion de
peine pour lui laisser sa chance voilà
alors on va raconter l'histoire ce qu'on
peut dire en tous les cas c'est que
votre mari
qui s'est réinséré totalement quand il a
vu ça quand il a vu qu'il pouvait encore
prendre huit ans en belgique il est
parti en cavale est parti en cavale il
est ou pas je m'en sors bien bonne
question je ne repense pas la
setca
voilà il fait du rab ouais voilà vous
avez des nouvelles missions avec les
portables
il vous appelle vous avez pas peur qui
repère mais si
tu perds qui leur père j'ai peur qu'ils
arrêtent j'ai peur qu'ils tombent sur un
barrage il s'arrêtera pas qu'ils se
fassent tuer parce que voilà avec un
nouveau système politique
il faut
sérieusement vous avez retrouvé vos
anciens réflexes quoi sert la méfiance
voire avoir la parano castraise
totalement ses seins c'est horrible
c'est sûr que c'est un enfer gimone si
on n'y pensait plus dur quand il c'est
fini et quand quand on m'a appelé et m'a
dit ton mari est en garde à vue
alors vous avez connu en fait vous aviez
18 ans 1 un jour il ya une copine qui
vous dit viens on va faire le guet
devant une banque
je ne savais pas où j'allais j'étais
petit est bon à jeter un peu à la rue
parce que j'ai perdu ma maman j'avais 16
ans et moi je vivais au jour le jour je
faisais un peu n'importe quoi je me la
faisait comme on dit avec un peu
n'importe qui et oui elle m'a dit viens
on va se balader donc je suis parti avec
elle est effectivement je les ai vus
arriver en mai j'ai vu arriver deux mecs
en moto dont je suis un tendre et au
départ je ne voulais pas du tout quoi
quand j'ai vu ça ça ma
voix le soir vue du braquage il vous
appelle et vous dis je peux monter
oui ils étaient en bas de chez moi il
m'a dit je peux monter j'ai dit non et
il me disait mais toi balle quand il
était à la cabine téléphonique en action
mais c'est vrai il est monté et il est
monté et le lendemain la la caisse
d'epargne qui était au pied de votre
immeuble braquer comme la wii et c'était
mon agent mais en plus c'est votre
pognon qu'il avait piqué ouais
alors là je vais me crier il dit c'est
pas sérieux moi je dormais si les
parties le un math et puis j'en cinq
plaintes sirène vous d'un bois bas mais
vraiment et puis je me suis remis au
balcon et j'ai vu plein de voitures
arrivées de les policiers quoi et là
j'ai compris ce style qu'est ce qu'il a
fait mais qu'est ce qui m'a fait ce
possible et voilà quoi ouais mais c'est
quand même un coup de foudre parce que
vous l'avez plus quitté depuis quoi
ouais si on monte sur la moto je suis
parent 1 alors ce qu'il faut dire en
fait c'est que votre mari c'est quand
même un gentleman quoi c'était un type
qui a pas de sang sur les mains dit ça
parce qu'il n'a jamais visé de violence
y voilà moi j'ai assisté à pratiquement
toutes les cours d'assises et même des
gens qui étaient pris en otage par mon
mari qui je m'assois côté je savais pas
qui c'était qui m'ont dit bonne chance
et après
oui mais je suis
et puis c'est le roi de l'évasion votre
mari aussi il s'est fait la belle en
droit absolument incroyable quoi mais
des qhs ouais ouais en espagne et une
prison là qu'on appelle le alcatraz
d'espagnol l'attribution de la serial en
plein milieu du désert ici km de désert
il restait dix jours là un dix jours
comment il a fait comment il fait à
chaque fois
et du corps mais disons qu'à nîmes là la
preuve la première évasion s'est passé
avec molly tout simplement avec les
draps si le barreau classique le coût
400 m en dessiner un raid deuxième fois
il a deux fois il a filmé il a taillé
faux calibre dans le bois du tabouret
deux fois il a envoyé après le
morceau de bois en forme de seins
sûrement un calibre il a envoyé mêmes
journaux qu'il avait photographié quand
vous avez une vie incroyable avec lui
non on se rend pas trop compte quand on
est dans là dedans ça on vit au jour le
jour y a un truc rigolo c'est quand vous
fuyez les filatures par exemple vous
rentrez dans un grand magasin vous êtes
en jean pas maquillée pas coiffée oui
vous allez vous piquez noir
et quand vous sortez vous reconnaissent
pas vous laisser ça oui deux fois alors
vous avez deux enfants
une première fille qui s'appelle sandra
et quand elle a 5 ans lui dit tu sais
ton papa est un braqueur c'est son
métier ses volets des banques elle a
réagi comment la petite
baie à bon elle réagit pas bon moi je ne
pars d'un principe c'est que les enfants
il faut pas leur mentir parce que sinon
après il arrive toujours à entendre des
choses ou avoir des même si on veut leur
cacher quelque chose est bon il faut pas
prendre les enfants pour des idiots et
je pense qu'en vraiment en leur disant
la vérité ça alors ça leur crée moins
d'angoissé et
ouais ils peuvent pas ce n'est pas
spécialement de traumatiser aujourd'hui
elle en première littéraire l et par là
derrière ah bon elle est dans le public
ouais c'est vrai elle est au salut
est mignonne t'es pas spécialement
traumatisé son papa n'a jamais tué
l'écureuil
comme quoi ouais bravo vous êtes marié
avec segura donc en décembre 97 à la
prison de gradignan et là il décide de
raccrocher à vous y est sans doute pour
quelque chose et de faire un deuxième
enfant une petite fille qui s'appelle
talia oui voilà mais parce que la cavale
c'est pas une vie assez lent de faire
quand même puis bon
j'en avais marre et puis bon il savait
que j'allais être là
et puis que pour beaucoup quand on a des
enfants il faut aussi leur donner leur
chance en voilà à cette enfance pour
vous cet enfant vous le faites au
parloir quoi oui c'est ce qu'on appelle
un parloir sexuelle ouais oui parce que
je suis ici maintenant d'ailleurs à
gradignan là où tout maria fait la
plupart de sa peine où il est sorti de
gradignan disons est pratiquement
c'est dans des boxes et dans des
couloirs cc vitré en boîte ou quoi donc
c'est ça fait 3 mètres carrés il ya des
petits bancs de chaque côté donc voilà
on a vécu notre vie sexuelle
pendant des années je peux vous dire que
ma libido en a pris un coup quand même
voilà il ya aussi à voilà et maintenant
alors on peut même plus s'asseoir sur
les genoux 1
comment on fait alors on est bien on
fait rien voilà au fériés et les élèves
ça n'existe pas en france et là ils ont
fait 10 pas en arrière ces dernières
années depuis le nouveau gouvernement ça
ça arrête c'est l'horreur 6e la droite
veut pas qu'on baisse dans les pays
veulent pas comme les prisons non la
droite se marier mais on n'a pas le
droit 1 alors je suis pas dans le code
civil je suis pas si vous tirez vous
allez à votre femme bien juger
puisqu'elle existe que bref ma femme
elle veut pas ben non je veux pas le
divorce et à ses torts main un mariage
et pas consommer c'est pas un mariage
quoi il faut rester dans leurs caves où
vous êtes arrivé à le consommer dans des
conditions un peu périlleuse quand même
à bois d'arcy
ah oui oui
je suis la seule à bois d'arcy oui oui
j'ai pas honte de le dire à bois d'arcy
c'était fait exprès pour lui couper la
chicane voilà et là bas c est carrément
mais c'est que du plexi c'est en rond à
mes yeux la whey non là bas vous avez
gueuler pas ce que vous dites mais moi
j'ai ma vie à autour de deux gratuits
vous le dis à 4 heures du matin pour
vendre des fleurs sur les marchés tout
ça pour subvenir aux besoins de votre
mari et un jour on l'emmène à bois
d'arcy et lave toute votre vie est à
recommencer
il reste trois mois mais bon il revenu
après à gradignan et il a fini sa peine
il est sorti de gradignan il a fait dix
ans de prison il a payé sa dette à la
société quand il est sorti il est devenu
technicien informatique dans une société
qui s'appelle etc au micro ça s'est
super bien passé rapidement il est
devenu cadre et puis un jour son patron
lui a demandé d'aller monter une filiale
de cette société anime donc c'est un bon
élément c'était une très bonne et les
mains son patron dit même qu'il a sauvé
l'entreprise à bordeaux parce qu'il en a
une aussi à toulouse il va faire aussi
sur paris voilà alors vous vous avez
lutté pendant des années pour arriver à
ça c'est à dire être avec votre mari vos
deux enfants à la limite métro boulot
dodo pour vous c'était un rêve et non
pas du tout une punition on peut dire il
avait échappé à la voyoucratie il était
un exemple de réinsertion cité dans les
médias et puis voilà la belgique leur
état la loi perben 2 équipes y retourner
et là il a rien à voir un plus anodins
la première fois qu'il est rentré en
prison il avait déjà rien à voir avec
l'histoire qu'on lui reprochait il a
fait 20 mois de détention provisoire
avant de ceux de s'évader avec son frère
aîné et il n'avait pas d'autre choix il
n'avait pas de parloir le juge
s'acharner sur lui lassé de nouveau ni
reparti au début quoi parce que la 93
nous on était plus en belgique on était
plus en belgique il a été jugé il
n'était pas là et si c'est inconcevable
ça je sais qu'ils avaient collé cette
affaire sur un autre français un que je
peux pas citer son nom ici donc c'est
pas ce france elle a eu un non-lieu
bombe segura il est passé par là on va
lui coller à lui même n'y était plus là
bah ouais voilà et ça s'il ya une
enquête mais là il va le même pas
l'ouvrir le dossier lorsque terrible en
plus c'est ce qu'il fallait pas revenir
sur leurs erreurs
je sais pas ça à faire on ne veut pas
passer pour des couillons voilà alors
c'était dans cette histoire c'est la
petite talia qui acquit à 6 ans c'est
l'horreur et qui dit à son père tu
m'avais promis que tout retournerai
jamais en prison
c'est ça le plus dur jourdain
si c'est ça c'est ça qui me lie à quoi
parce qu'ils sont derrière leur bureau
se rendent pas compte qu'ils passent des
lois je suis d'accord je me sens
vraiment royalement voilà je m'en fous
au nom de la coordination européenne
judiciaire pour le pour le terrorisme ça
a été fait au départ pour les
disparitions d'enfants je suis tout à
fait d'accord là dessus il aurait dû le
faire même avant voilà mais qu'il nous
lâche anne quoi moi ça m'amuse pas de
venir sur les plateaux de télé qu'on me
reconnaisse dans la rue et qui me lâche
pendant deux ans j'ai plus militer j'ai
plus emmerdé personne j'ai pu ramener ma
gueule nulle part mais qui nous foutent
la paix voilà et non il faut qu'ils me
le prenne un qui me le replonge dans les
qhs avec comme motif s'est évadé il ya
quelques années à 18 ans en arrière
quand même hein et voilà maintenant que
me l'envoyer en belgique pour 8 ans et 6
croyez que je vais rien faire et ça veut
dire qu intégration possible non voilà
non mais s'ils croyaient pas à la
réinsertion mais ça existe pas la
réinsertion les deux icônes un conte a
contacté tout ça c'est des mensonges
c'est des conneries qu'est ce que vous
comptez faire là pour poser votre mari
dénoncé au maximum que les gens que
l'opinion publique qu'ils arrêtent de
ces c'est grave ce qui se passe en ce
moment parce que moi maintenant quand
j'ai connu la prison je croyais et je ne
savais pas la prison ce que c'est et je
crois que c'est dans un autre pays c'est
là à côté de chez nous alors on parle
des autres pays dessine mais les
tortures tout ce qui se peut se passer
dans les prisons dans les gardes à vue
des gens si vous saviez ce qui se passe
c'est l'horreur absolue on parle du
nazisme ce moment ni qu'on aille faire
un peu un tour j'ai vu un député
apparenté gym et chami a mis un pied
dans une prison oui on va vous la faire
visiter mais alors on va vous faire mal
et choisir les cellules on va vous faire
on va vous faire parler le début des
tenues choisies aussi parce que si elle
n'a eu qu'à l'homme alors de l'ouvrir je
peux vous dire qu'il va se fait taper
dessus quand on vend de prison c'est
qu'on a commis un délit qu'on n'a pas
respecté la loi mais les prisons il ya
eu un constat l'assemblée nationale
c'est pas moi qui le dit des zones de
non-droit des zones de non droit moi j
étais en prison jamais passer devant le
tribunal j'ai jamais volé une petite
cuillère jamais eu ni un jour de prison
avec sursis pourtant on m'a mis deux
fois en prison ma fille ces quatre mois
et demi de prison elle a fait 5 jours de
garde à vue alors qu'à l'époque c'était
48 heures la garde à vue comment
m'expliquer que ça
alors si haut si on est là pour pour
payer quelque chose parce qu'on a fait
des conneries il faut au moins que ce
soit reste que que il respecte le les
droits c'est pour ça que je me suis mise
à militer pour m'aider à supporter la
situation la séparation de mon mari est
depuis plusieurs personnes qui militent
avec plusieurs femmes de nord de prises
pas à militer parce que de suite dès que
vous même faire signer une pétition la
première punition si le transfert sur le
détenu s'est les brimades sur brimades
c'est c'est l'enfer à l'époque du
nazisme il y avait des gens monstrueux
se dit comment il ya des gens qui
peuvent faire des choses comme ça faut
pas croire qu'ils existent plus ces gens
là c'est pas parce qu'on n'est pas en
guerre ou laisser les pervers lisent ils
sont l'âme il se cache derrière des
beaux costards et je peux vous dire
ouais alors après on se demande oui le
bon et le mauvais moi je me pose la
question parce que ce qui est terrible
c'est que il a fait ça en belgique et
donc la belgique avec le mandat d'arrêt
européen aujourd'hui peut le réclamer
alors que l'italie n'a pas accepté sa
voix séparent à l'italie s'il avait fait
ces braquages en italie tu tentes et qui
les effets utilisés avait fait en italie
il serait pas emmerder c'est
complètement surréaliste et c'est de la
folie mais tu vas quitter la france et a
pas d'autre solution pour garder la
liberté de ton mari à la tienne
mais bon je ma fille qui en première l
là elle a un petit copain qui est
adorable
c'est ma petite et les allées on va dire
voilà c'est voilà tout et puis bon quand
on n'a pas le franc comme on fait quoi
tu peux pas m'en a pas tous montés dans
la voiture et partir comme ça comme alan
40 quoi moi ce que j'espère c'est qu'ils
trouvent un arrangement et qui me lâche
la grappe quoi qui me qui nous lâchent
qui nous laisse bosser tranquille vous
pensez que le fait de remous que je vais
vous dire quand je me suis enchaîné ça
part et ça n'a pas coûté grand chose de
machines et j'ai pas risquer ni ma vie
dit rien mais alors c'était juste
l'entrée après va venir le reste quoi
l'asim là je peux vous dire que je pense
qu'à ça je tourne je viens j'ai perdu 8
kilos je suis pas bien mais je
trouverais croyez moi je suis dans mon
bon droit je suis dans mon bon droit
j'ai rien à me reprocher mon mari il a
été libéré les sorties par la grande
porte il a rien à se reprocher mais bon
voilà du v4 tu peux venir ici pour en
parler chaque fois que tu veux merci
d'accord il faudra continuer plus en
parler voilà j'ai plus envie d'en parler
parce que la prise enrico le mot prison
à sa mort
[Applaudissements]
on peut dire quand même mais qu'un
intrus qui est positif là-dedans c'est
la force de votre amour pour lui c'est
sûr c'est sûr extraordinaire comment
voulez mais là mais je n'ai pas écouté
j'ai pas trouvé mieux après 18h avec lui
j'ai encore pas trouvé c'est bien vous
avez qui combien de temps ensemble sur
18 en disant m 85 80 semble
neuf en disant
et si c'était à refaire pareil ben vous
de l'amour j'aimerais bien être à sa
place en tout cas c'est vrai je me dis
encore avait très bien comme ça c'est un
shérif pendu
lens ce qui est dit est dit vous revenez
quand vous voulez pour nous tenir au
courant quand vous voulez
et
allez
oui
pour tout court après quand on a fait 14
émissions de promotion et enfin mais toi
tu veux commencer puis qu'on voit
quelqu'un qui vient la presse qu'il n'y
a pas d'autres moyens et que pour sauver
la peau de son âme et ça c'est
magnifique
qu'elle pourrait faire c'est prendre ce
galles comme attaché de presse elle
ferait 14 émissions d'une semaine par
semaine je sais pas
bien
marine delterme et florian zeller je
vais vous laisser rentrer à la maison
c'est ce que c'est un
amoureux ça fait le temps de jeter un
verre d'eau sur la guerre j'ai manqué
c'était une bonne occasion j'ai manqué
une bonne occasion bah oui si tu me dis
être vraiment dégueulasse peut-être que
j'ai à te dire merci à tous les deux
[Musique]
c'est sûr mais ils font beaucoup plaint
tous les deux non ah oui c'est vrai dire
un son bien ouais
c'est le couple est à la mode
j'accueille un autre couple à la mode
guy bedos et gabriel valence
à
bonsoir
comment ça va
ça va
j'attends qu'ils aient fini d'applaudir
pour répondre oui tant rien bien à vous
arrivez du théâtre hébertot oui tu vas
tout petit peu enrouée moi ça fait
partie du personnage mois et alors ça a
marché ce soir mu très bien les gens
rigolaient comme le soir où j'étais oui
c'est odile ont été émus enfin c'est
incroyable a weekend succès ses passions
les rappels au sérieux non non non non
non moi j'aimerais bien faire plus je
bois possible parfois je pouvais sauter
la pièce est de faire que
vous arrivez du théâtre hébertot vous
jouez sortie de scène de nicolas bedos
qui est le fils de guy vial histoire
quelle histoire mise en scène par daniel
benoin vers moi non mais ça va pas déjà
l'hôtel m'a fait vaudé tout à l'heure la
non mais ça va située au lieu-dit abîme
surnom s'appelle benoît benoît rhinois
ça fait bédouins
non alors il ya aussi elisabeth margoni
ça va ça oui jean louis tripp ça va oui
et cyrille eldin voilà ondimba el dine
non ndiaye teint elle d'accord oui
quelque chose l'histoire comme tu veux
tirer la future usine toi tu es là faire
alors c'est l'histoire de pierre
montceau interprété par guy bedos qui
était un auteur de vaudeville à succès
dans le temps et qui vit reclus dans son
salon depuis dix ans c'est une espèce de
misanthrope atrabilaire sa carrière au
boulevard lui fait horreur il était
cette image que le public a de lui et il
a renoncé à tout ça à ce succès pour
écrire des pamphlets des lettres
ouvertes aux politiques sur les dérives
du monde moderne mais ça marche pas très
bien
il est malade il vocifère sans faim
devant sa femme de ménage gouvernante
dont il est le grand homme et c'est là
que débarque gabriel bonsoir oui elle
valency ravissante mais désespéré aussi
par le monde moderne et ce qui est très
étonnant c'est que vous ne connaissez de
lui que ces pamphlets en fait toutes ces
pièces de boulevard tous ces vaudevilles
qu'il a fait avant vous les connaissez
pas et voulait mais pour ce qu'il est
devenu voilà la seule d'ailleurs ouais
et voilà j'en dis pas plus après faut
que j'en ai voir la pièce est d'accord
mais bien sûr il ya aussi un animateur
télé dans la pièce qui est pas piquée
des hannetons oui l'animateur télé 1 il
est pire que toi ouais ouais mais c'est
vrai mais sérieux il est d'un cynisme
oui je me suis pas du tout reconnu
on se demande où ni que d'aller chercher
et puis un jeune auteur alcoolique et
monde a alors on sait aussi où il a pris
ses modèles miscéo matisse rue de
ponthieu c'est bien le genre de mec qui
traîne à cet endroit là et pas les nuits
ils m'ont fiche l'inde ya quelques
années alors en tous les cas j'essaie
excellence est bourré de deux formules
assassines c'est drôle c'est lucide ac
c'est plutôt bien pour certains si j'en
crois ce qu'on me dit qu'on nous dit
c'est émouvant orgie
j'en ris mais ils sont touchés ouais
et ce qui est bien aussi c'est que
personne depuis que je joue cette pièce
de maddie alors vous reprenez quand le
one man show oui
je suis assez d'accord avec ça oui oui
c'est bien de te voir maintenant même si
je reviens au one man show je dois t'y
faire un
je fais ce que je veux d'accord
alors
il ya une scène où vous fumé un pétard
tous les deux qui est absolument génial
c'est un moment d'anthologie tu parles à
mesquer à oui mais moi ça me fait moins
rire que toi
bah oui c'est moi je suis plus tu es
plus résistants bah oui qu'est-ce qu'on
habitude jean moulin du tampon
mais oui c'est vrai que c'est une scène
qu'on a tous les deux est bon oui oui
moi je suis totalement novice l min 6 à
ça et c'est un des moments un moment
fort la pièce quand il monte sur la
chaise et éclate de rire c'est un moment
fort de la pièce est là où leur
complicité se crée vraiment c'est à ce
moment là que ça va basculer ce qui est
émouvant c'est c'est le passage de
relais entre deux générations
et cette jeune femme
apprennent des choses de lui et que lui
apprennent des choses d'elle est quelque
chose de je crois qu'il ne laisse pas le
public indifférent
c'est bien ce que j'ai dis bien c'est
pas bien lorsque vous allez faire
maintenant vous avez regardé votre
caméra tous les deux ensemble et vous
allez dire magnéto serge
magnéto serge
et vous savez pourquoi jeter ma part que
c'est votre métier chez moi et puis
c'est au rire j'aspire n'est pas le rire
je perds ma demande bien où il est
aujourd'hui sourire que vous cherchez
c'est une interview vous êtes
journaliste non mais je suis une de vos
admiratrice et ce depuis la première
heure
est encore plus vieille des planchers
régler une vieille présente les
admiratrices depuis la première partie
de génie go qui se régalait de mai
pochade
viderait qu'il ne trouvait pas aussi
stupide que ça
quand je rentre chez moi je vous relier
la nuit et je ris tout seul oh mon dieu
vieille femme crie tout seul la nuit
dans son lit ça me dégoûte un peu
les quelque chose le libidineux là
dedans comme si vous me parliez de vos
plaisirs solitaires mais ce morceau de
shon
la sortie de scène le nicolas bello
c'est au théâtre hébertot
avec guy bedos et gabriel valency fusil
la betterave l'un c'est vraiment toi les
gens se marrent quoi c'est vraiment un
truc qui va marcher ça va être dit il ya
un bruit qui court dans paris j'ai pas
encore vu la piège du bigger in de
meilleur téléphone triple rébillard
expliquer à quel point ton fils écrivait
bien parce que ton talent on le connaît
mais il paraît que au delà c'est pas du
népotisme il n'a pas pris son gamin
parce que c'était son fils il paraît que
c'est avec des petits s'il ya un
auditeur extraordinaire et moi je vais
dépêchés de venir vous voir il paraît
qu'il est une bien jolie salle en parler
paraît qu'il s'est enrayée très bon la
critique est pas mauvaise on a parlé
d'anouilh dans dans le figaro le figaro
d'une très jolie soirée tendre et drôle
en parlant de l'auteur nicolas bedos il
est doué ce jeune auteur en parlant de
vous une comédienne délicate très juste
qui refusent les facilités émotionnel
surtout ils ont rien ne
vient pas tout lu
un
jeu ronronne j'adore ça ouais dans les
succès j'adore ça et puis surtout ce
rôle c'est le plus gros mouvement c'est
un rôle qui convient à maturité je
l'exagèrent un peu sonné sans pousser en
ayant laissé pousser la barbe parce
qu'en fait c'est ça oui mais
bien briller elle fait du théâtre depuis
l'âge de 12 13 ans non c à vous a pris
mais ça m'a pris j'ai été dans un camp
de théâtre une fois et puis j'ai adoré
ça et bien su tout de suite que c'est ce
que je voulais faire j'avais fait la
même beaucoup de musique à vent mais
sans vraiment savoir si c'était ça ou
pas et puis voilà le théâtre vous avez
pris des assurances pour quelqu'un qui à
vannes camion donc je crois que j'ai
tout pour être sécurisé et puis et c'est
un bonheur tous les soirs moi je suis en
plus c'est l'expérience parce que tous
les soirs on ne se lasse pas moi je me
lasse pas d'entendre ce que fergie je me
lasse pas de relire le texte enfin et
c'est extrêmement riche c'est drôle
c'est c'est fabuleux que demande le
peuple tout va bien voilà et les gens ne
reçoivent
avec beaucoup d'intelligence et ça fait
plaisir alors il y en a un autre qui
étonne avec son âge c'est donc nicolas
qui a quoi 24 en attaque tu dois être
très très fier parce que le talent est
pas forcément transmissibles je veux pas
non plus sortir les violences d'alou sur
le père le fils fils non non c'est pas
moi c'est un auteur geci sa pièce avait
été mauvais je ne leur ai pas joué ouais
mais laissons qu'avec pauthe il ay là il
a quand même une maturité incroyable
qu'est ce qu'il a il a vieilli
prématurément quoi mais je me sens plus
jeune que lui parfois franchement ggd de
candeur
qui sent ridicule à côté il a une
maturité de quinquagénaires je trouve
mais il a grandi et guy bedos aussi mais
moi j'ai dit guy bedos il a sperme
artistique très fertile parce que leslie
bedos moi j'ai j'ai lu son livre je suis
gaucher aller a écrit un livre
magnifique la grand mère et je la
connais un petit peu et je trouve
qu'elle aussi elle est pas dénuée de
talent tu me permets que je
ne connais pas sa part
connaît pas toute la famille j'ai deux
autres filles qui viennent bien
c'est vrai qu'il voulait quitter l'école
déjà l'âge de 80 ans fils oui j'étais
obligé de dire à nicolas jim dine en
échange on conduit j'ai déjà tout
compris
l'enlever de l'école c'est interdit par
la loi il va y avoir les gendarmes il
voulait quitter l'école à 8h01 barbey
ailleurs b et un jour ma femme est
rentré en me disant alors le mot a été
prononcé ton fils est un surdoué voilà
peut-être qu'il va s'en sortir je sais
pas on va trouver un moyen de
sylla il avait une maladie grave à 19
ans il était quasiment cadres supérieurs
et canal + 1 avant que ça ne devienne
canal - ouais
[Rires]
et alors à la sorbonne est resté une
demi heure quaïda regarder le plafond il
a dit c'est joli c'est bien la thaïlande
avance il s'est mis à écrire un film
parce que tu as été beaucoup plus tenté
par le cinéma au départ c'est un garçon
qui a été menée
dans les salles obscures
et voilà que dire de plus nicolas bedos
bordeaux
allo
[Applaudissements]
il fait rire du rire parce que ça leur
dit il mais bon il me dit j'ai des
nausées jeudi de va pas venir je suis
rares dition à peine arrivé mais bon
voilà mais je vais me tenir là c'est moi
tu as pris quoi du lexomil du tranxène
du valium du xanax je peux dire la
vérité oui j'ai pris un quart l'exo un k
way va voilà parce que je suis
terrorisée voilà je suis meilleur à à
l'écrit qu'à l'oral je crois dans ton
métier c'est mieux un bon après je suis
là mais je suis content en tous les cas
que tu as fait un sacré portrait de ton
père tu sais pas si c'est un bon
portrait de mon père va bien relancés en
tout cas
non mais je pense quand même journée on
est traversé par carey je pense que
quand un jeune romancier écrit un
premier livre un premier roman il règle
des comptes il pense à son passé à ses
anciennes petites amies à ses parents
moi ce qui est plus pervers de la
situation c'est que je lui fais jouer le
personnage avec lequel parfois je règle
non pas des comptes mais enfin c'est pas
une c'est pas un miroir très
complaisante des casques et ce qui est
très touchant dans l'histoire c'est que
toi tu avais peur de lui faire lire la
pièce que tu avais peur ça lui plaise
pas lui là ils avaient peur de la
massacrer en la jouant donc à une espèce
de pudeur entre vous qui êtes assez
touchante c'est à dire que voilà là on
est par exemple assis l'un à côté de
l'autre moi si je regardais ma télé je
me dirais voilà il ya le fils de à côté
de son papa ça m'agace ray enfin donc on
avait envie d'éviter ça parce que je
sais pas ce qu'en pensent les gens qui
sont contre à nous regarder mais moi je
trouve le grand le grand le grand
couillon à côté de son papa qui a écrit
une pièce chère mais voilà il faut que
je vienne au théâtre puis là c'était
mauvais s'exprimer c'est comme marilou
berry week est une bonne comédienne
voilà que ça soit la fille de balasko
tout le monde s'en fou qui d'autre
aurait pu jouer la pièce michel serrault
jean louis trintignant je lui proposais
jean louis trintignant c'est vrai qu'on
a on a en a on a voulu éviter ça sert qu
en l'écrivant je savais qu'il la joue
très très bien ré ce monsieur et puis on
a voulu éviter ça alors je les proposer
à jean louis trintignant qui m'a fait
l'amitié ça m'a énormément flatter parce
que ç'a l'air intéressé et donc j'ai
reçu c'est un comble être que je vois là
que je garderai toujours placardées dans
la chambre de jeune tina m'explique
quand clubbers oui peut-être mais et
voilà ils pensaient qu'ils n'avaient pas
l'humanité là et la drôlerie qui
pourrait permettre à ce vieux con de
montceau de de séduire et de et de
d'être supportés par le public parce que
quand même ça commence haarde c'est très
acide et il fallait toute l'humanité de
ce monsieur pour faire avaler la pilule
mais arrête de m'appeler monsieur quand
même tu exagères
[Rires]
ça va faire très chaud au coeur quand sa
progéniture vous propose d'une création
comme ça de d'entrer dans son univers ce
qui m'amuse et en plus c'est que c'était
un peu un message que je veux envoyer à
cette époque là je vous aime parce que
le personnage de la pièce en fait est un
est un personnage qui en fait rond
complètement comme vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure avec le genre léger avec
l'humour avec le rire avec tout ce qui
pourrait à un moment donné le le
culpabiliser de ne pas parler des
affaires du monde et ça fait chier tout
le monde d'ailleurs parce que l'on ne
passe son temps à lui demander de
revenir vers quelque chose de plus
efficace et je crois qu'au moment où
j'ai écrit cette pièce j'avais aussi
envie de dire à moi mon père d'une
certaine façon ce que je pense qu'il est
parfois de tenter par le sérieux et par
la gravité et il le fait d'ailleurs
assez bien mais j'avais aussi envie de
le ramener vers vers vers le spectacle
vers le vert le vert le plaisir du ver
le faire la différence essentielle entre
le personnage que je jouais et moi c'est
que moi mes colères mes indignations mes
convictions et c'est je les ai mises
dans mes choix d'oracle et les salles
sont pleines
tu comprends donc j'ai aucune raison il
n'y a pas de rupture il n'y a pas de
rupture ce n'était pas de fracture tu as
deux phrases terribles la première c'est
qu'il sait faire du du drôle avec du
triste qui est formidable et l'autre je
suis entré dans mes années courte c'est
à dire quoi que j'ai 70 ans et que
logiquement
bah voila quoi jeu vais je me donne
pour vivre comme j'aime c'est à dire
pareil car je vis exactement de la même
façon tout fonctionne de la même façon
que quand j'avais 30 40 ans etc et pour
cause parce que voilà j'ai pas le droit
de faire autrement
mais il y avait un moment où je vais
devenir président tic et j'aimerais
sortir avant génétiquement dans sa
famille on vit choix
99e et là on en parlera quand tu feras
mémoire d'outre-mer oui tu reviendras
oui diane oui j'étais bien les pugétois
c'est ça ou
moins drôles ce soir sa démission
[Applaudissements]
on va faire une interwiew patriat
[Musique]
guy bedos quels conseils donneriez-vous
à un jeune comique qui débute
je lirai ses textes abordent et si je
pense qu'il est doué
bah je lui conseillerais de continuer et
même je l'aiderai ce m'est arrivé est un
vieux comics et des buts
ça peut être émouvant
vieux comics qui débute
d'abord je partage avec desproges la
version pour le mot comique pour moi un
comique non je parle d'eux d'humoristes
de satiriste
d'amuseur éventuellement mais comique
pour moi c'est un adjectif ont dit ne
brandit pas la dramatique qu'isabelle
adjani non on n'y pas le tragique
francis huster du cinquième fois
que
je les dirai quel conseil donneriez-vous
à guy bedos jeunes
de continuer
quels conseils donneriez vous à un
humoriste qui se prend pour guy bedos
d'arrêter
quels conseils donneriez vous à un
humoriste qui ne veut pas de conseils de
guy bedos
de continuer
de se démerder et d'aller crever
c'est ce qu'ils ont tourné
quels conseils donneriez vous à tous
ceux qui n'aiment pas guy bedos de
continuer j'adore mes ennemis je les ai
choisis et si tu n'aimes pas c'est
qu'ils ont des raisons et moi j'ai des
raisons aussi de les détester très bien
quels conseils donneriez-vous à
dieudonné
de ne pas faire d'heures supplémentaires
de jouer ce spectacle
c'est tout voilà
[Applaudissements]
quels conseils donneriez-vous guy bedos
à lionel jospin
pour faire 2-2
de ne pas prendre l'île de ré pour
colombey-les-deux-églises et et
surtout qu'il y reste ah oui oui quels
conseils donneriez-vous à dieu guy bedos
tu vas répondre
tu vas répondre à sa question
je lisais un je ne sais pas je donne des
conseils à quelque chose qui n'existe
peut-être pas un nom en tout cas s'il
existe franchement il est pas en forme
ces temps-ci
car vraiment quand on dit dieu est amour
et je sais à qui je parle moi je pense
que dieu est pas mort connard
[Applaudissements]
quels conseils tu me donneras moi
je trouve que
ça a été les les 15 premières années qui
ont été plus dur mais je trouve que tu
fais des progrès avaient vraiment et
c'est vraiment bien je pense que dans 20
30 ans ça sera épatant
[Musique]
sortie de scène de nicolas bedos mise en
scène de daniel benoin c'est au théâtre
hébertot et le texte est publié à
l'avant scène
[Musique]
je suis venu car selon megan
vous devez dire du mal de votre films ou
livres ou disques yes l'auteur s'était
imposé par ta femme on peut lire
ses fins
[Applaudissements]
connaissez pas ta mère elle est
vachement sympa hein dis non bon alors
je dis du mal de la pièce toi
ce que je dirais c'est que c'est que
elle me fatigue et que dans la journée
je ne ne peux plus je ne peux plus rien
faire et de plaisir à sa mère voilà et
que je suis obligé de dormir pour être
en forme le soir voilà et que j'ai je
donne je suis des restes j'espère
qu'elle n'aura pas trop de succès quand
même parce que je pense qu'à un moment
j'en aurai marre
[Musique]
tirer une carte avant de partir j'en ai
bien déjà j'en ai déjà tiré une au piano
dans une autre émission
alors qu'un vous devez voter pour
éliminer à des invités à des invités
présents tu t'es des mines toi même tu
josiane balasko part
parizeau jade
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien sûr
j'accueille houston
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
aller
alors c'est vraiment la soirée des
surdoué ce soir parce qu'on a eu florian
zeller on a eu nicolas bedos maintenant
on à joss stone c'est incroyable savait
que des jeunes très talentueux vous êtes
la nouvelle voie delà de la soul vous
dites je n'ai jamais pris de cours ma
technique les faibles mais ma voix est
un don du ciel
eh bien oui je pense que c'est ça
la raison pour laquelle j'ai dit ça
c'est qu'en fait j'ai pas pris de court
et j'ai commencé après après pour faire
des tournées mais en fait je n'ai pas de
technique j'ai vraiment pas technique
finalement que je suis
dit qu'elle n'y peut rien ouais c'est
comme ça elle a 17 ans
salut passera vrai alors
vous êtes houston un véritable phénomène
votre premier album de soul sessions
s'est vendu à plus de 2 millions
d'exemplaires dans le monde et donc
aujourd'hui vous publiez votre deuxième
album qui s'appelle mind body and soul
et pour vous vous dites c'est votre
premier vrai album en fait parce que
c'est le premier où il ya des
compositions originales c'est plus
seulement des cover des reprises
mais c'est vrai plus si
le premier album c'est un petit peu
comme un accident c'est un petit peu un
hasard
ça devait vraiment pas vraiment sortir
mais je crois que les gens auraient aimé
c'est pour ça qu'on a un fait un album
alors sur ce deuxième album il ya des
contributions extraordinaires qui
abaisse guy box de portishead
oui ouais c'est lolo demande et celle un
petit copain
de rien
d'accord glissé l'a déjà fait l'amour
il ma grande joie crushed voilà
il veut que je vous demande si vous avez
un buzz fans
oui oui en effet j'en ai un il est
génial
et d'ailleurs il a écrit une chanson sur
la bonne spa est ok
donc sur cet album il ya baisse guy
bones de portishead ya là mon désir qui
a composé tous les grands types de la
tamla motown
il ya betty white qui vous a beaucoup
aidé pour cet album just du groupe du
groupe chic julien lepers cas pas une
musique qu'elle a refusé il a fait ça
julien théâtre
à
voilà et c'est pas votre album ça c'est
julien lepers ça c'est mes très doué
aussi
il a fait pour le plaisir aussi vous un
indice chez vous 1 à 0
[Musique]
etc
m
quel était ce moment-là
est ce que vous connaissez orlando
orlando du nord orlando
[Musique]
puisqu'un vous savez le frère de dalida
orienté avec une hausse de ghanem
orlando
bloom
je connais personne connaissent et
parlant d'eux parce qu orlando exige le
clip hollande au chac foi qui est une
chanteuse qui vient initiants ils
exigent le clip non sauf pour christine
deviers-joncour il rien c'est vrai
qu'à raison alors l'arrêté royal mais là
ils exigent le clip alors vous allez
regarder votre caméra
l'occasio caméra prise de one with the
red light own and youth et magnéto serge
magnéto magnets et au magnéto maniacs
away certes c'est ok magnate aux sages
ouais
[Musique]
moe ue
mais c'est pas mal non
m
voilà you have been
body and soul nous
joss stone quel autre invité ce soir
alors elle est formidable dont khalid
abu à quel âge c'est extraordinaire bon
alors y c'est extraordinaire a pas dans
la disco doha fin s est vraiment c'est
vraiment un don du ciel c'est incroyable
cette voie que vous avez
et joe king
guilloteau la note jockey avoir chez
puis au non vraiment c'est bien alors
quand vous étiez enfant la seule chose
qui vous intéressait en fait jaws
c'était de chanter sous la douche les
chansons d'aretha franklin
c'était un magnéto
je crois que
la chanson d'aretha franklin que vous
préférez c'est natural woman
gelé beaucoup peiné avant de la chanter
et puis
c'est ma préférée
c'est comment
pendant un pommeau de douche à chanter
maintenant de recevoir ils vont de showa
cesse vos
efforts
ce biker
ça continue ainsi
alors à 14 ans vous avez fait une
audition pour la bbc pour une émission
qui est un petit peu comparable à
graines de star en france s'appelle star
fahrenheit vous avez chanté natural
woman de harry frère francklin et
ensuite pour l'émission vous avez
ferrone de radio de donna summer
c'est ce que j'ai chanté pendant
l'émission mais à l'audition s'était
nature woman c'était bizarre
d'apprendre ses chansons parce que
j'étais une petite fille j'étais blanche
et j'ai dit je voulais chanter ces
chansons là et ils me l'ont ils n'ont
pas voulu me laisser choisir ça donc
c'est un petit peu difficile ouais alors
on a eu des difficultés mais finalement
j'ai pu les chanter
c'est comme ça que tout a commencé avec
cette cette émission de télévision sur
la bbc star fahrenheit et après c'est
parti votre premier album de soul
sessions si l'album favori de tom cruise
il a déclaré dans un talk show aux états
unis vous savez ça tom cruise il a dit
que c'était il écoute et votre disque en
boucle nuit et jour
il est très sympa disque avec tellement
de succès aux états unis vous avez été
invité à la maison blanche je vais
rencontrer george bush
1 il était très sympa en fait mais il
m'a rappelé
mon voisin d'à côté il est il est paysan
d'ailleurs mon voisin d'écouté
on était dans weeds est voisin sur la
tête du monde et sa femme elle est
comment les moches non non c'est un nom
les buts jolie et pitt jolie elle était
très sympathique n'a pas le droit de
vote non pas que c'est tant mieux
bois
tu sais qui c'est qui la monte de
0 nous ferons mieux c'est le père de
votre petit ami d'amanda lear
[Musique]
j'espère que tu es tube de la tamla
motown
il a écrit ça c'est un vrai génie et son
fils rites et tout cela s'est passé par
les jeunes et il est génial c'est quand
même un peu comme nicolas bedos et guy
bedos c'est une soirée de gene
vincent
et bientôt bientôt en angleterre pas
bien le
voir le show man show dance hall c'est
son deuxième album est là messieurs
josh merci merci d'avoir été avec nous
karim achoui a tout de suite se rend
bien compte
[Musique]
les albanais sympa et super à un navet
stone que le nom d'anne way alain de
stone que le nom qu'est-ce qu'elle a
vieilli moi je l'avais reconnue à 14 ans
ouais dans son vomi comme jay joplin ça
dépend tu sais pas si j'en suis sûr ah
bon ouais c'est une époque en même temps
on a là une voix exceptionnelle avec
sept chiots national health coach tout
le monde voilà maintenant j'accueille
élise galant et romain icard
là
bonsoir ellis galant romain icard vous
êtes un grand reporter à france 3 et
vous publié aux éditions privé un livre
qui s'appelle suzy qu'entre mon gros
loup oui c'est les abandonnent la sntf
saman voilà très bien c'est la sphère du
mystérieux groupe azf alors je rappelle
la sphère le 3 mars 2004 et les jours
suivants on n'a parlé que de ça la bande
azf une bande terroriste qui menaçaient
de faire sauter des trains dans tout le
pays oui et puis on n'a plus jamais
entendu parler ça a duré quoi dix jours
la fernand médiatiquement ça durait pas
très longtemps mais malgré ça dure un
peu plus longtemps voilà alors au départ
à zdf c'est le nom de l' usine qui
expose à toulouse que tu connais bien
guy comme tu as beaucoup faire un des
blessés voilà c'est vrai que j'ai été
très troublé par jeu ceux-ci azf parce
que pour moi c'était quelque chose de
très de très douloureux et de très
estimable ça n'avait rien à voir avec
ces gens là
j'avais il y avait du brouillage la
volonté lisez le sigle catastrophe
pour peut-être signifié qu'il voulait
être à leur tour explosif alors dombasle
chantage on le connaît il ya une bombe
sur le réseau ferré français
si le gouvernement ne paye pas la rançon
voilà ça explosera et on trouve une
bombe d'ailleurs trouve de bons ont
trouvé deux bombes on trouve une
première bombe sur indication du groupe
et puis quelques semaines plus tard on
trouvera une deuxième bombe un peu par
hasard hasard un peu d'ailleurs étrange
là aussi à un moment où jean pierre
raffarin est à quelques kilomètres
seulement de cette bombe en campagne
électorale ouais c'est ce qui fait que
plus tard un posteriori en prenant un
peu de recul et en analysant plusieurs
faits on se pose quelques questions sur
cette histoire ouais alors il ya un truc
qui se passe d'abord qui est
extraordinaire en france qui n'était
jamais arrivé c'est que nicolas sarkozy
décide ce qu'on appelle une opération de
muselage c'est à dire que quand les
camps les journalistes voulaient premier
d'ailleurs vous sentez que quelque chose
qui se passe à 100 oui parce qu'elle ait
tous les journalistes qui s'occupent
comme ça de la justice de la police de
ce qu'on appelle les faits divers
pendant plusieurs jours il ya plus
d'interlocuteur on sent quelque chose de
bizarre il ya deux les policiers qui
sont appelés de absolument partout en
france en renfort sur paris donc on sent
les choses bizarres plus personne répond
il ya vraiment quelque chose de très
diffus jusqu'au jour où les rédactions
vont carrément recevoir un fax du
ministère de l'intérieur demandant aux
journalistes de se taire et expliquant
que voilà il ya une affaire avec un
groupe qui se fait appeler à tdf qui a
décidé de racketter de rançonner l'état
français et qui faussent terre pour les
besoins de l'enquêté ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est à dire que en fait
le ministère de l'intérieur confirme
qu'il ya bien quelque chose qui est bien
une demande de rançon une menace sur le
réseau ferré mais on demande journaliste
pas en parler ce qui est absolument
c'est complètement dingue parce qu'il
raconte tout en plus parce que en
substance il ya quelques journalistes
dont c'est la spécialité qui connaissent
un petit peu l'histoire mais pas
beaucoup elle a d'un coup toutes les
rédactions après l'événement
scénario a raconté dans son sens
tellement schizophrène c'est à dire
qu'on balance l'info à tout le monde et
en même temps dit taisez vous 1 alors à
ce moment-là tous les journaux obtempère
façon générale sauf un oui c'est la
dépêche du midi qui décident de passer
outre les consignes parce qu'en plus la
dépêche de jimena toulouse toujours
toujours il ya un truc à toulouse tout
on a tendance à laisser les mangas été
trouvé sur une voie ferrée en direction
de toulouse sur la ligne paris tôt pari
tenu
alors pourquoi pourquoi bell et décide
de publier la nouvelle il décide et
vraiment il ya eu beaucoup de demandes
faites avec insistance à la dépêche du
midi pour que la dépêche thèse
l'information puisque le chef de cabinet
de nicolas sarkozy lui-même claude
guillon va appeler le soir sur son
portable le rédacteur en chef et mesbah
il est également en lui demandant de
surseoir à la publication et le
directeur de la dépêche du midi a décidé
de publier en posant une seule question
est ce que c'est vrai claude guéant
répondra oui dit alors nous publions
voilà et le lendemain ce temps des gens
on prend pas nous offre place beauvau 1
et en disant si ça pète on veut pas
avoir la responsabilité de nous voir
expliquer le mot lecteurs qu'on savait
qu'on n'a pas publié
il a finalement dit chacun son métier
quoi les enquêteurs enquêtent les
politiques diriger nos journalistes ont
la forme voilà
ben oui mais on leur a reproché un peu à
oui parce que pendant un moment le
coupable c'était plus la cdf c'était la
dépêche du midi et c'est à vous de
montrer très bien dans votre bouquin
alors ce qui est extraordinaire aussi
c'est que le gouvernement négocie alors
qu'on a toujours dit on ne négocie pas
avec les terroristes enfin c'est le leit
motiv habituel là le gouvernement
négocié le paiement de la rançon ce qui
est déjà nouveau et communique avec azf
alors là c'est le gag par
l'intermédiaire de petites annonces dans
libé donc c'est c'est très drôle alors
d'un côté d'un côté il négocie parce que
forcément pour attraper les auteurs de
ce chantage il faut évidemment tendre un
guet-apens donc pour communiquer azf
demande à ce que les policiers publie
une petite annonce dans libération mon
gros loup
sommes d'accord pour négocier tu signes
et suzie donc jusque-là bon
90e 2 à 1 et il avance dans le
guet-apens qui veulent tendre à asa
d'offres mais en fait très vite ils vont
faire venir la rançon des états unis
et claude guéant toujours des directeurs
de cabinet nicolas sarkozy nous
confirmera ils ont fait venir tout cet
argent en pensant qu'un jour il pourrait
être amené à payer ce qui nous agace
évidemment sans voix quand on a entendu
nous confirmer cela
la france n'a pas quatre millions de
dollars en petites coupures de
disponible sans faire bouger le marché
du dollar en europe et ce qui pouvait
être un problème tout le monde aurait
percuté qu'il se passait quelque chose
on a de l'or mais pas demain donc il a
fallu aller à la réserve fédérale aux
états unis et leur demander 4 millions
de dollars alors la remise de rançon
raté ça se passe comment c'est épique la
demande de rançon ça commence par les
changes des petites annonces mais c'est
un scénario absolument hollywoodien
il demande une remise de rançon par la
voie des airs en hélicoptère et au début
ils demandent un hélico qui seraient
stationnés en haut de la tour
montparnasse
avec les pales qui tourne en attente de
décollage karl est évidemment possible
place beauvau au ministère de
l'intérieur c'est la stupéfaction a
jamais demandé un truc pareil ils
réfléchissent et ils vont dire non non
pas pour faire pour négocier avec les
terroristes mais uniquement parce que
pour des questions de sécurité et pour
des questions de redécollage de
l'hélicoptère c'est impossible de se
poser sur la zone h en haut de la tour
montparnasse donc ils vont re publié une
petite annonce mon gros loup l'oiseau
blanc doit s'envoler d'ailleurs contexte
on ou s'ils vont cisi tout ça continue
et finalement azf va téléphoner
puisqu'il est donc allé numéro de
portable codé qui sont publiés dans la
presse et azf va téléphoner et va dire
aux policiers l'hélico peut s'envoler
d'ailleurs et donc d'une base militaire
en banlieue parisienne et l'unc anti
petit partent pour livrer l'argent ils
doivent livrer l'argent sur un foulard
bleu une bâche bleue et puis la baci la
trouve pas un don qui livrent pas mais
alors c'est incroyable parce que ce
jour-là il ya l'hélico qui porte la
rançon mais il ya trois autres hélico
avec des policiers du raid sur équipés
en opération commando
il ya d avion des douanes il ya même à
rendre un avion awacs qui est un région
ademe
navarro est au dessus des lois justes
parce que c'est la procédure il ya deux
mirage 2000 en vol rob est sur le
terrain il ya plus de 400 policiers sur
le terrain rés mais ne trouve pas la
bâche quoi il y avait un sac de billets
où il y avait des émetteurs aussi
savaient qu'ils avaient ils avaient ils
voulaient pas prendre le risque de
laisser partir l'argent canadiennes sauf
que au final il n'était même pas sûr que
l'argent et enfin l'argent pouvait
éventuellement s'en aller sans qu'il
soit il le rattrappe passe quand les
balises en plus montré qu'un très très
capricieuse et il suffit que vous
bougiez un petit peu trop fort les sacs
que ou que tout simplement j'en sais
rien les ravisseurs aient pensé à mettre
une espèce de cage de faraday dans le
coffre de la voiture ou de la tapissée
de papier alu évidemment la balise je
vais m on apprend plein de trucs en même
temps un ce qui est incroyable
en fait l'état français la république
française a été complètement manipulé
par azf qu'il a fait faire les pieds au
mur du dessert oui puis ça se termine
comme ça a commencé à élire président de
la république en 2007 a priori sarkozy
qui s'est fait manipuler par des petites
annonces de cul dans libération c'était
clairement jugé bien sérieux de cette
histoire c'est lui parce que suzy a à z
y c'est le premier d'ailleurs à s'en
rendre compte c'est le premier à se
rendre compte que suzy c'est sarkozy
c'est clairement lui et sa salle agace
un peu d'ailleurs ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que en fait tout
s'arrête comme ça avait commencé
c'est-à-dire par un courrier quoi c'est
au revoir à bientôt sans rancune ya
bientôt et bien tu es béliveau en fait
c'était
c'était ce retrait sur chaise je viens
ici n'est pas la bombe parce que
vraiment la bombe qui est découverte la
première bombe qui est donc c'est le
groupe azf qui donne des coordonnées gps
sur un courrier les enquêteurs se
rendent sur place et les voix sont
absolument normal et puis à des traces
blanches le sol donc ils se mettent à
gratter et enfouie sous 20 centimètres
sous les cailloux sous 20 centimètres de
ballast il découvre un tupperware avec
la région avant
ces des ménagères en colère enfin les
moins de 50 ans les fameuses est donc
évidemment il découvre un nouvel usage
du tupperware puisqu'à l'intérieur il ya
deux explosifs et un détonateur et une
mise à feu extrêmement perfectionnés
détonateur qui leur fait penser que
c'est pas beau niveau parce que ce
détonateur c'est pas sur internet qu'on
trouve la formule pour le coup pour
fabriquer quoi là il ya un truc vraiment
vraiment pointu qui ressemble
franchement du militaire
congolo troubles mon salaire ou je fais
péter le studio
[Applaudissements]
tout de suite c'est joli ce métier rien
n'y fit en bas du message merde alors
l'enquète n'a pas abouti au départ on
dit c'est les islamistes et les corses
et les basses et les bretons pas du tout
on s'aperçoit rapidement tout suspens
qui existant pour venir sans les bretons
non mais les bretons ces deux trois
pneus brûlés sur une départementale
alors à un moment on pense effectivement
que ça pète le milieu secteur c'est à
dire que les flics vont voir christian
cotten qui est le gourou d'antoine sous
l'ère que nous connaissons bien ici le
fils de didier suler bon côté nous là
vous l'avez vu vous aussi d'ailleurs il
dit oui on nous on nous casse les
couilles parce qu'on fait des enquêtes
sur des trucs un peu grave mais en même
temps bon on n'y est pour rien et
finalement la piste je dirais la moins
fantaisistes c'est le service d'action
civique c'est à dire le sasac parce
qu'en wi ex pasqua ça serait un coup
anti-sarko monté par des barbouzes
gaulliste malgré la dissolution du sac
en 82 après la tuerie d'auriol ça reste
aujourd'hui quand même cette tentative
de déstabiliser sarkozy par des
barbouzes disons téléguidé par l'extrême
droite voire par l'elysée ça reste quand
même aujourd'hui l'hypothèse la plus
probable d'après votre bouquin en tous
les gens qu'on a vu on leur a posé la
question est-ce que vous est ce que vous
allez penser à une manip tous nous ont
répondu oui ouais tous même claude
guéant directeur de cabinet de nicolas
sarkozy après don à des degrés
différents certains nous disent dans la
rue balaye d'un revers de main d'autres
moins alors le sac pour le sac ça
n'existe plus officiellement elle ça que
c'est fini depuis quelques années
maintenant mais ce qui est certain c'est
que l'extrême droite française
la vrai dur et paramilitaires à la une
connaissance technique et elle a une
vieille histoire en france de ce genre
de manip mais surtout dans les périodes
électorales toujours fait le jeu du tout
sécuritaire est vrai parce que ce que
vous remarquez c'est que l'affairé azf
commence au moment des régionales et
s'arrête à la fin des régionales un jour
avant le second tour ouais vraiment il
ya une concordance de dates pour le
moins curieuse après est ce que c'est
une manip ou pas nous on peut pas
l'affirmer mais une chose est sûre c'est
que générallement tout criminel commis
une faute une erreur quelque part là le
groupe azf ils vont envoyer 9 courrier
ils vont passer cinq coups de fil ils
vont organiser une remise de rançon ou
ils vont balader tous les pontes de la
police française ils vont poser deux
bombes sur les voies ferrées et avec
tout ça il n'y a pas une piste quoi ya
pas un indice il n'y a pas une erreur à
une trace adn pas une empreinte c'est
pas des niveaux bien muselé par claude
guéant effectivement le dircab de sarko
vous êtes avec lui sarkozy arrive salut
comment ça va sympa et quand guillon lui
dise en train de faire un livre sur la
zdf d'un seul coup c'est le masque mais
il aidera il a l'air moins à l'aise
ouais il reste pas lyon oui alors qu'il
est tout sourire et avenant comme comme
on connaît tous un nicolas sarkozy
effectivement là il se fige le sourire
s'efface et il tourne les talons il s'en
va à ce moment là qu'il n'a pas envie
d'en parler mais c'est une épine pour
lui c'est sûr qu'il veut pas en parler
ça nous on lui a fait des demandes il
refuse de s'exprimer sur le sujet au
greffe ouais il s'est jamais exprimée
dessus voilà à l'époque alors qu'on est
en pleine campagne électorale et que
d'habitude on connaît notre ministre de
l'intérieur comme étant très présent
dans les médias
sur suzy contre mon rôle où il garde un
mutisme absolu quoi faut dire dans le cv
ça fait un peu bizarre mais c'est ça
parce que sur son cv c'est la seule
tâche ben bishop colonna il jean teulé
plusieurs mois mais bon en l'occurrence
officiellement disons que sur son bis à
l'intérieur sur son bilan
il n'a rien médias quand vous dites à
claude guéant son dircab est ce que ça
serait pas finalement une tentative de
déstabilisation de sarkozy etc
il vous répond je préfère pas y penser
ça va tenir je préfère ne pas y penser
donc aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas la
preuve formelle évidemment vous avez
étudié le dossier le bouquin est très
très informés mais c'est quand même
l'hypothèse la plus plausible pour vous
c'est en tout cas nous ce qui nous a
arrêtés parce que parce que parce qu'on
n'a jamais connu ça en france et que et
que vraiment la police a travaillé comme
d'habitude on parle souvent les enquêtes
raté foire et là les mecs qu'ils ont
bossé ils ont bossé comme des fous ils
sont allés vérifier entendre le moindre
mec qui avait joué avec de l'explosif
dans son jardin sur les 25 dernières
années ils ont fait les cartes bleues et
tous les brico relais machin partout en
france pour savoir où là bas j'avais pu
être acheté par c'est un travail de
dingue qu'on appelle fermer toutes les
portes ils les ont toutes fermé les unes
après les autres il n'y a rien et ça on
a souvent tendance à rigoler des flics
en france machin va-t-il mettre les
moyens quand même souvent ils sont pas
si mal avec ça mais là en l'occurrence
ils ont mis beaucoup beaucoup de moyens
ne sont jamais que des gens qui
connaissent et leurs méthodes voilà ils
ont jamais ils n'ont jamais mis autant
de moyens celle enquête la plus
importante qui est depuis la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale et avait eu
autant de moyens sur une enquête
policière il chope rien pas une
empreinte adn et à des relents de est ce
là dedans oui je pense être juste que le
sac je pense à yann rolland 2 es un peu
de vent qu'ils avaient imaginé donc de
rajouter une lettre à z f ce qui donne b
à g bague qui sont retransformés donc
bagega le sac et voilà comment on arrive
au way qui a trop qui a fait sa chérie à
magistrat rien à impôts faire des
conneries pareilles il travaille
beaucoup pensez
vous continuer à travailler sur la ferme
et bien
évidemment on lis très attentivement les
petites annonces tous les jours dans
tous les quotidiens et on imagine plein
de trucs derrière
j'hésite entre mon rôle ou
et puis échec l'idée
[Musique]
il
du
et
[Musique]
j'accueille helena noguerra
non ça va
les verts
enfin
j'ai bien vous avec votre barbe
on se connaît non non c'est déjà croisé
ça fait combien de temps qu'on a de lui
au voilà si on le dit à chaque fois ça
ne l'est pas le dire sinon non mais on
peut enfin le relais peu leur président
mais en même temps fallait préciser à
couper dans ses mains non mais ça ne
dérange pas je les aime bien ça va ça va
et voûté bénin merci sur son mac os des
cardinals c'est vraiment donc gg un beau
futur ouais merci
helena noguerra mannequin chanteuse
animatrice comédienne écrivain vous avez
pas envie de rencontrer un bon
conseiller d'orientation une fois pour
toute quand vous trouviez ce que vous
non mais c'est toujours la même chose
mannequin c'est obsolète c'est son
époque dans ma vie voilà je les fais ça
m'a acheté du temps libre il le reste
c'est toujours la même histoire c'est
raconter des choses avec des supports
différents ouais je chante où j'écris où
je voulais comédien est animatrice en ce
moment aussi un bon sur sur tps non
c'est fini c'est obsolète aussi ah bon
ah oui ils vous ont déjà arrêté j'ai
quitté la télé j'ai fait mes adieux ah
oui c'est dommage parce que ça vous a vu
j'ai suivi les conseils de bruno bah oui
mais sait on faisait un petit revenu
quand même assez surpris que c'était
plus un bandeau ah bon c'était un peu
plus confortable quand même ça
aujourd'hui mais je préfère bah oui
parce que vous dit toujours que vous
avez peur de manquer ce que je comprends
très bien vous dites j'ai peur de
vieillir son travail sans pouvoir me
payer à bouffer me payer un toit c'est
comme ça ça vous inquiète beaucoup un
ouais ça fait partie de mes angoisses
oui c'est la route est longue en
principe fin on sait pas a peut-être que
je meurs demain ouais et tant mieux mais
si c'est pas si c'est pas l'heure c'est
quand même nom comme route moi même je
veux dire un truc que j'ai gagné ma vie
d'ici là j'ai un peu angoissé comme
fille j'ai pas marie toi mais c'est fait
ça c'est le pire qu'elle pouvait
répondre
c'est fait voilà non mais c'est vrai
vous avez été mur à ces jeunes et
vieilles assez jeune et vous avez
toujours eu peur de manquer et je vois
que vous traitez tous avec une
désinvolture devient petits boulots la
sûreté ps la movistar 6e c'est sympa si
sûr c'est un petit pécule 6 et digne
comme un boulot c'est pas le journal du
hard non plus certes ça me permettait de
subsister c'est vrai mais en même temps
je bosse j'avais envie de faire mes
adieux à la télé oui d'accord je tenais
un peu la famille pour connaître un peu
je suis ami avec sa soeur new
bell sont comme ça ouais les soeurs by
jybo libre et bien en plus c'est vrai
que votre compagnon vous pousse vers des
choses plus crue philippe katerine non
ah non il ne pousse pas
disons que c'est un révélateur c'est
quelqu'un qui
qui me convainc que je peux m'exprimer
et que j'ai le droit de le faire et que
je suis intéressante mais mais pas dans
le sens
je sais pas parce que il vous demande
d'écrire des chansons comme vous écrivez
des livres c'est à dire avec la même la
même noirceur d'une certaine façon non
mais en tout cas la même
la même comment on dit franchise c'est
vrai que jusque jusqu'à jusqu'à la
j'écrivais des chansons en essayant de
faire plutôt jolie où la poésie ou un
maquillant doivent être les choses et
que c'est quelqu'un qui m'a poussé à
être peut-être plus frontale et puis
direct et peut-être plus honnête bah oui
mais bon deux mois déguisés les chaises
vous trouvez ça mal je n'aime pas ça mal
du tout mais de la morale n'est pas du
tout je fais pas la mort mais je fais du
souci pour vous là bas comme je sais que
j'avais peur de manquer je me dis qu'est
ce qui va se passer tout ça mais non
mais ça va lui tant mieux bon alors dans
votre dernier album là par exemple est
dans la nature il ya une chanson celle
qui était en promo qui s'appelle l'âge
de ma mère ces cycles cru quand même non
c'est direct c'est direct ouais je me
suis créé au camp messin seront par
terre quand j'aurai l'âge de ma mère
tout ça va c crosser davantage des
petits sun valley parce que tous ces
trucs pas
c'est vrai se rétracter
[Musique]
comme échoue
on
ce que tu es tu iras
damien freixa
[Musique]
c'est que je manquerai
c'est bien
[Applaudissements]
oui il ya des chances quand vous avec
philippe quatrième reprise aussi que pas
mal
et
m
je sais
et
à tanger maroc
il
oui
c'est l'amour
t
je sais
et
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi cette
bravo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jours
jean
[Musique]
mais c'est vraiment fort j'ai réussi
l'attitude avec olano et tuia il ya
plein de bonnes chansons c'est vrai puis
philippe katerine n'est pas le dernier
de sa classe alors m c'est sûr c'est ça
[Musique]
bien étonné que ça soit bien
vingt ans à temps et malgré tout c'est
quand même vous monsieur ardisson qui
avait pas ses lunettes noires dans
lunettes noires et blanches en même
temps faut il que vous y êtes pas pour
rien non donc là alors mais oui sur et
fait semblant
non mais on aime bien le fait que vous
aimez bien je m'inquiète ma chère amie
de votre côté obscur c'est tout oui
parce que ça fait dur épreuve s qui
aurait pas un peu d'humour noir dont je
sais pas on va voir on va faire une
interview côté obscur
[Musique]
non c'est un vrai côté obscur est ce que
tu as déjà volé dans un magasin
régulièrement le barça bon en fait une
montée d'adrénaline il ne l'est plus
c'est pas terrible là il est bien son
pull j'adore vraiment ce emmaüs est ce
que tu as déjà pensé au suicide
ah oui souvent est-ce que tu t'arraches
les cheveux des fois ça m'est arrivé
également tu fais craquer t doit
annoncer jeudi à souhaiter la mort de
quelqu'un ah oui
j'avais plaisir
tu as déjà bu du sang ah non pas du sang
merck même le boudin j'ai du mal est ce
que
est ce que les cicatrices et 7 etc si
quelqu'un annonce à m'excite pas mais je
trouve ça joli je trouve qu'on fait
toutes les filles font des bisous sur
les cicatrices des hommes et vice versa
j'aime bien vous à mexique pas ce débat
je vous dis pas non plus à tanis mal
employé chez toi non apparent
enfin c'était déjà pratiquer la magie
noire non la magie blanche mais j'aime
bien coupé des petites mèches de cheveux
des gens que j'aime bien les enterrer
sous là sous le sable et faire des
prières comme c'est un peu païenne
j'aime bien cette idée quand je
dis moi elle n'as tu pourrais pactiser
avec le diable non ah oui
oui côté obscur est ce que tu as déjà
fait de l'amour en nombre impair en
nombre impair c'est à dire les jours
impairs way nombreux appels 3 à 3 5 à 15
non non vous avez oui c'est ça le
nanisme tout seul ouais ouais ouais
ouais et ses bonnes réponses et ce que
tu as déjà
frappé un enfant
c'est cool non
et comme c'est agréable quand il tombe
comme ça c'est pas marrant c'est pas
drôle je regrette je regrette alain vrai
côté obscura guy tu trouves pas est ce
que tu as déjà porter un slip en cuir
hip hip hip est ce que tu as déjà vu tes
parents faire l'amour non qu'est ce que
tu as fait l'amour dans le lit de ses
parents
chez plus mais je crois que oui déjà été
filmé en train de faire l'amour tu as
déjà à sucer le pied d'un homme oui les
orteils sont parait que c'est super et
la douche on n'achète pas j'ai pas
séparément une photo
d'après john ging dis moi tu as déjà
partagé un copain avec une copine
non
non non tu as déjà l'écouter tes voisins
baiser bah c'est pas que je les ai
écoutés c'est qu'il ya on les entend
est ce que tu as déjà eu envie de goûter
de la chair humaine
non mais c'est con mais c'est tentant
moi je connais les gamins c'est pas mal
imaginez j'avais bien dire aux enfants
pendant la nuit je me réveille et puis
je vais vous cuire dans le four je
mangeais beau petit
épisode
tu veux tu veux manger maintenant
évidemment que j'ai fait manger mais
j'aime bien cette idée
ena
c'est le site non mesdames messieurs
[Musique]
ambassadrice
mais non non je n'ai pas dit que je suis
en train de jouer ou shayna club le 3
février le 31 mars et le 1er avril
parce que c'est plein de succès alors
c'est vrai c'était l'affiché suivante et
le pardon sera en concert au china club
le 3 février le 31 mars et le 1er ep qu
avec des enfants
alors maintenant mais lisez ce qu'on
peut lui faire une petite carte
et à sao la
vous remplacer thierry ardisson pendant
10 minutes
[Musique]
je sais pas où je ne me les poser à moi
c'est pas parce que tu vois si tu ardues
sont des sites internet s'étant temps
vous êtes toujours là
un
truc énorme vous êtes vous et ouais il
ya un très bon cheval c'est maintenant
non mais parce que vous posez toujours
des questions inouïe à tout le monde et
puis on voulait pose pas donc je
reprends juste vos fiches parce que j'ai
pas trop d'idées dont vous n'êtes pas au
china club
alors est-ce que vous avez déjà écouter
vos voisins baiser
malheureusement j'ai des voisins qui
sont très discrets je voudrais leur
lancer un appel si vous pouviez être un
petit peu plus ou alors si quelqu'un
connait c'est un appartement qui donne
sur des voisins exhibitionniste je suis
preneur
est-ce que vous avez déjà suisse et le
pied d'un homme jamais et le pied d'une
femme non plus je me rends compte est
bon et je le regrette j'ai tendu ma wii
lui donnons un peu
moi qui suce le pied ta gonzesse toi
tient de ville
je pense à la conclusion
inverse
vers
23h10 s'ils ont un
est-ce que vous avez déjà et partager
votre copain avec une copine non mais
une copine avec un copain oui
mais alors moi c'est sympa c'est rezaï
la cua bah oui les nombreux impairs
c'est génial lien et puis
gravit bah oui bah tant que tu trouves
que si c'est un pc puis dégueulasse
qu'est ce que tu manges avait jamais
fait si je n'ai jamais fait c'est parce
que je n'aime pas
tellement d'oral pourquoi vous le faites
pas ça m non j'ai pas pensé je vais le
faire en rentrant j'ai pas pensé détails
mais sucer les orteils c'est un truc
j'ai jamais pensé c'est roger nsingi
ses nuits de fond ça j'ai dit j'ai un
trou dans ma chaise c'est justement ce
rapport oui c'est vrai c'est pratique
qui paraissait non
attends attends attends attends excusez
moi je suis thierry ardisson depuis
trois minutes
timide a été continuellement tête
service aussi
alors cette fois on passe vraiment blind
test
voilà alors pour jouer avec nous je
rappelle thierry frémaux
et
j'appelle et dj clément julienne
[Musique]
bonsoir vous connaissez le principe
d'abord c'est par équipes c'est l'équipe
de nicolas bedos contre l'équipe de lna
et ensuite ce sera le chacun pour sa
gueule voilà ça sera commis en espace
détente après ça sera ultra libéralisme
on rigolera plus du tout du tout du tout
attention ah mais non mais vas-y répond
ah tu sais c'est pas c'est qui ces mots
l'attaché de presse
il faut juste allemand est ce qu'on est
prêt ouais carrément bien recommencer
normand ce numéro un
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
et il le sait
sony
allez
bravo bravo thierry guibault wenger qui
veut nous l'avait dit mais tu l'aies
voilà je pense que tu l'as dit avant
bien enlever de la bouche mois la soupe
alors allons-y numéro 2
[Musique]
voilà
donc ça fait quoi ça fait deux points
pour nicolas bedos zéro point pour elena
ça tout ça commence toujours comme ça
fait un come back inouïe après l'annoncé
de l'équipe de nicolas bedos et on
confie ses chefs d'église n'a rien
trouvé le maire d'ailleurs j'arrête
j'arrête c'est plus l'équipe d'elena
c'est l'équipe de guy bono c'est
l'équipe de nicolas bedos contre
l'équipe de guy bedos voilà c'est mieux
a le sens du concept elle surtout le
contrat j'ai dû greg la merde je vous
frapperai alors dit
[Musique]
oh
non
et
ouais
ce
[Musique]
qu'il a dit en premier serge yvan
ribéry
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tiens
[Applaudissements]
l'équipe de nicolas denos arrive disait
au point pour l'équipe de guy bono smala
alors j clément julienne
[Musique]
comment une passe
tantôt
amano
[Applaudissements]
les big boys ouais ouais
or
[Musique]
maty de fruits
c'est
riche d all good beat
11e ont marre ils la trouvaient ses
frais mon cas trouvé cette occasion la
politique de nicolas valeur continue
paiement julienne
[Musique]
non
robot 10
1 points pour l'équipe de guy bedos ont
continué hier j'étais au bahut avec ce
avec arrêté comme j'étais au lycée on
est battu
on continue
[Musique]
donc ça fait 4 2 quand même un sarment
de ce côté là car nous avons choisi cet
archer d'ihs
mais moi j'y allais
robin les deux animatrices les jours
[Musique]
c'est l'amer d'accord 5,3 à temps pour
la callas c'est pas loin c'est pas loin
clément julienne
attavanti oui oui
[Musique]
celle-là il a intérêt à la reconnaître
parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on la joue
ensemble dans notre petit groupe il
ajoute tellement faute d'accord ça joue
juste la suite
je savais qu'il swinguer comme une
chaussette comme lui
on est à 5 4 comment ne pas y vend
à vous
[Musique]
soit
b
m ça fait 5 5 ha ouais alors ce qui est
génial c'est génial
j'étudie wendy m6 et diers hosni vous
êtes une équipe formidable très soudée
très uni la faisselle collectif qui vous
a fait baisser la pression sûrement
d'être un peu comme un entraîneur de
foot je suis comme un terrain tu vois
ses bases pour tuer mais je te jure rien
g55 c'est
alors au prochain
[Musique]
ces bonus qui t'appelle pour dire qu'il
faut c'est tiré
comment ça va khadr ce cas d'air
ouais ça va ça se passe bien mais en
plein de la une thèse on n'a toujours
pas fini ouais
ça va oui c'est super ils sont à 5,5 il
ya nicolas bedos contre guy bedos ils
sont à 5,5 au blind test nicolet n'y est
pas pour grand chose rappelle en sortant
chabal bon on continue
[Musique]
et voilà donc maintenant il reste un
morceau dans le par équipes si c'est
vous qui marquait vous les exploser si
c'est vous vous êtes à égalité donc
c'est pas le moment de la pratique
lichens je n'étais pas le moment de me
lire attention
à éviter
[Musique]
et voilà
oh
mieux le sas à l'époque lui des plus
jeunes voilà aussi si donc il ya égalité
également il faut en faire un de plus
pour non mais faut en faire un de plus
pour départager les équipes pourront pas
rester sur cet égard il ressemble pas
ton émission quoi il faut quelqu'un qui
gagne qui écrase l'autre non c'est pas
ça va faire un match et intérêts si j'ai
ça attention vous êtes prêts c'est toi
qui l'envoie
[Musique]
elle
beaucoup
d'amour et coups envers moi
c'est un vin le superman henry lui
la tour
le fera
n'était ce pas
non plus
et
[Musique]
je
hélas
leur master gagner là dessus c'est ou
sublime uni ouais vraiment cher qu'au
championnat ben il a pas d'excusés il
est là ce soir
alors maintenant un an passé la série
des bons coups donc la séquence dans
l'espace détente chacun pour sa gueule
sortie de l'ultralibéral n'y a plus
d'amis
alain madelin qui commande la maladie
alors avec ce pavlov chez moi tient
alors commencer par le liban ce qu on
commence doucement le mini banco
attention là c'est chacun pour soi
[Musique]
c'est la beauté
on me
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aurore
cox voilà tu l'aies mais c'est bien
mardi
tu l'as entendu moi est forte absolument
moi
repris par claude françois effectivement
et par sylvie vartan c'est la même chose
c'est la même galère on continue
[Musique]
me tarde d'y avoir c'est la reprise
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
thibodeau
c'est dans la bande originale du film si
c'est pas
du chantage je te connais trop il vante
un grand bluffeur aux joues moisan de la
trompette voilà grosso s'appelle
s'est passé la limite rom petegem c'est
l'original ça c'est l'original original
tu sais pour l'instant mais les
poseurs
m
ouais
c'est
non non j'ai dit tu as un pont entre al
green ça pourrait être effectivement
otis redding c'est wilson pickett oui ça
les philistins non plus qu'il était chez
atlantic millstone tout cas qu'il
n'était pas chez stacks franc continue
personnes à gagner bons coups
mais deux
même maison bbc
et
[Musique]
on les connaît c'est quoi
il s'est comporté
ce nom
c'est juste à côté
elles ont fait ils ont fait ainsi son 2e
match qu'ils ont fait aussi olsson à une
commune isolée ses morceaux c'est pas
les noms ben c'est une honte ça va tu va
nous dire toi j'ai peur j'ai peur
peut-être aussi ce nom vannes n'est pas
à proton c'est ça bravo comme bravo
et pourtant
toi aussi tu as roma
domaine des mutins
ah alors attention maintenant le
mega man cause celui ou celle qui va
trouver ça sera le roi ou la reine de la
soirée il faut qu'on peut le dire lors
alléguée de l'anguille c'est un mec que
tu peux trouver je te jure tu verras tu
verras c'est un mec que tu peux trouver
chercher leur andré claveau sûr je sais
tu pas jean sablon mais c'est un mec de
cette époque ah oui oui un américain de
cette époque tout ce que je peux dire on
y va on y va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la fonte bravo je pense que cette série
je pense qu'on peut dire que thierry
plus de qui que ce soit
c'est quand on étudie sa gueule en début
d'émission
sa gueule et puis voilà aujourd'hui
leurs résultats
harry belafonte je pense que tu aurais
pu le trouver oui bah oui je pense que
tu l'aurais trouver si tu avais laissé
une belle aux turcs avaient si bien sûr
ils étaient très bien selon
[Applaudissements]
laurent qu'est ce que je rappelle que le
5 février ya ce dvd qui sort même si guy
bedos a offert un à ce qu'est l'espace
mais il ya plus de trente comique ça
coûte 15 euros il ya dix euros qui vont
aller à la croix rouge et tant qu'on
parle de la croix rouge le mardi 2
février c'est la dernière la 500e de ma
pièce on donne tout le profit à la croix
rouge également voilà donc au comédien
comme dans les jours suivants c'était
une ambiance
josiane balasko thierry lhermitte karin
viard viol sans qui le veut
bruno solo yvan le bolloc'h thierry
frémont espace détente de bloquer solo
sorti le dieu
jda bande originale du film espace
défense merci
marine delterme et florian zeller le
manège de florian zeller au petit
montparnasse
laurence segura merci pour votre
témoignage danse il s'agit pour vous
aidera s'il le faut qui veut dose
gabriel
nicolas bedos nerf ou
sortie de scène nicolas belot ce défi vu
d'autres bryn evans aussi au théâtre
hébertot et un coffret dvd rw et le
coffret tout ça trompe énormément avec
nous irons tous au paradis montebourg
qui veut dossier génial
joss stone l'album s'appelle my body and
soul ya aussi un dvd isabelle mind body
and soul kitchen income soeur voilà
ellis galant et romain icard fusil
contre mon rôle ou aux éditions privé
helena noguerra l'album s'appelle vie
dans la nature elle est en concert au
china club le 3 février
et on a une baisse via mans julien
[Musique]
merci
concert au profit d'unicef france pour
les enfants d'asie du sud avec jane
birkin vincent delerm laurent korcia
mardi 1er février à 20h au théâtre du
châtelet voit
ses pieds
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le
tous
m
[Musique]
les corrections de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus